Wait Baby Jesus on a pogo stick.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience.
This is a late night episode,
is brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is the all in one platform
that makes it fast and easy for you to
create your own professional website
and not like a bullshit professional
website, but like a really dope website.
I say dope. I'm almost 50. How about that?
I'm 46. I say dope. I don't give
a fuck. Say it cause I mean it.
They make dope websites.
Uh,
Squarespace has beautiful designs for
you to start with and all the style
options you need to create a unique
website for you and or your business.
I know you probably like,
there's no way I can do this.
This is too fucking complicated.
It's as easy as sending an email with
a picture in it. If you can do that,
if you can attach things,
if you can drag and drop,
it's very simple stuff and they offer 24,
seven support.
You can make your own business and
you can start an online store with
Squarespace in a wicked easy fashion.
Squarespace also even has a logo creator.
You can create a clean customs simple
logo designed for yourself in minutes,
Buti fullness all by yourself.
Each design automatically includes a
unique mobile experience that matches the
overall style of your website. So if you
make a website website on Squarespace,
you can look at it on your iPhone.
You can look at it on a kindle device,
you can look at it on a laptop,
you can look at it on your
fucking android phone. You get me?
You understand what I'm saying?
Mac, PC, whatever, whatever.
For a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and
enter the code word Joe.
That's squarespace.com and the
code word Joe. It says Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website,
but that's ridiculous because the
web is pretty fucking awesome. Ready?
Change that Shit Squarespace.
Anyway,
Joe rogan.squarespace.com
enter in the code where Joe,
we're also brought to you by stamps.com
and with stamps.com is a way to avoid a
lot of the nonsense that goes along with
sending shit through the mail. Like,
let's say you start your own
website with Squarespace.
You start selling shit at a Squarespace,
then you've got to send it. Oh,
good googly Mowgli son.
You do not want to have to
go to the fucking post office
and wait in line with a
bunch of other people that don't
want to be waiting in line and up.
Poor person behind the counter.
It's got to measure all
your shit and package it up.
You can get rid of all those steps and
handle it all completely from your home
while drunk and naked and it's totally
legal and you do it through your
computer. You stamps.com you
don't have to get drunk and naked.
It's just a suggestion and I don't know,
like how you deal with things when
you're naked or when you're drunk.
You might make poor choices,
so you might not want to use
stamps.com when you're drunk and naked,
but if you're sober in your home, you can
do, we'll do whatever the fuck you want.
What am I your dad?
My point is that you can print official
us postage right there from your home
computer.
Slap that shit on a box and weigh it with
the digital scale that they provide as
a part of this delicious $110 package,
which includes up to 55
bucks of free postage.
Squarespace is an awesome way to start
a website and stamps.com is an awesome
way to sell shit. I like that they go
hand in hand. Do you see how I rock shit.
Amy Schumer craziness.
stamps.com has been used by
Brian red band for a long time.
If you buy one of his cool kittycat tee
shirts that he designs and makes himself,
those are all sent through stamps.com uh,
it's also how Christina Palicki and Tom
Segura when they send your mom's house
stuff, they use stamps.com too.
It's an awesome, awesome service.
And if you use the Promo Code j r
e you will get this special offer,
which is no risk trial,
hundred and $10 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale
and up to $55 of free postage.
So go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type J r e that's
stamps.com and enter and j r
e or almost home Amy Schumer.
We're almost home where
at the homestretch.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t,
a human optimization website.
And that name was only created because
there's no other way to describe it.
It seems a little douchey and pretentious.
We're about human optimization, but uh,
that's really what we're about. So there's
no other way to say it unfortunately.
Uh,
it sounds good until you're talking to
someone who's skeptical and then looking
at you like, what bitch the fuck you're
talking about human optimization website.
What, what kind of nonsense?
Strength and conditioning equipment.
That's what I'm talking about,
bitch.
We still kettlebells and on it both
regular kettlebells and artistic ones,
we have these primal bells, which
are all the great apes, gorillas,
orangutans, chimpanzees and little howler
monkeys. And we also made Zombie Bells.
This is the most recent one.
All these were done by a guy named Steven
Shubin jr bad ass artist created these
awesome things and then we made them
out of metal and they are all three d
balanced. So although you know, they
look cool and everything like that.
We also wanted to make sure they're
completely, totally functional.
I use the 70 of course the gorilla because
I'm a fucking manly man and I've got
no time for your bullshit. And if you're
preparing for the Zombie Apocalypse, um,
what better way than prepare
with a fucking metal Zombie
head and they will last
you forever.
Like literally after the apocalypse
comes and the aliens land and they try to
decipher our culture,
they'll find a few fucking Zombie heads
and gorilla gorilla heads and you're
like, what the fuck are these people
into? They will never figure it out.
Mark my words, they would never
fucking figure it out. They were like,
they worship the gods of the
monkeys. No, you'd dummies.
We worked out with them on a.com o.
N n I t use the Codeword Rogan and
you will save 10% off any and all
supplements. That's o. N. N.
I. T. The code word is Rogan.
Amy Schumer is here.
Why fuck
around
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Amy Schumer. Hello. Can we
start every show that you're on?
Like that was a little song. Powerful Amy
Schumer Song. I would love it. Thank you.
So [inaudible] on stage that
way. Why not? You could do it.
You could demand that people have
riders. Yeah. Why do people have riders?
You know, I put a lot of weird shit in
there, like white m and m's and fucking,
I heard I have the cheapest.
The Guy I've been on the road was that
I have the cheapest writers ever seen it
as Lilly. Yes. Cheapest. Like
what's your rider? What do you do?
You will you require,
it's like honestly,
vegetables and fruit for a smoothie
with some Greek yogurt. It's just like,
he's like, yeah. And their wine, which
I tell him to hide from me unless I ask,
what about a Pale white sneakers?
I should do that. Cleaning hip hop.
I need a hip hop vibe.
I've gotten nothing where there's some
artists that do demand things like that.
They demand like, uh, every time
I go to one of these places,
I always asked the guys backstage like,
what's the craziest Shit you've ever seen?
Yeah,
because a lot of these dudes that are
like working in these comedy clubs or
these, especially these theaters that
have seen like rock and roll bands coming
through. Right. You always want
to know like what? Come on man.
What's the craziest Shit you've seen?
Just rock and roll coke stories for
the most part it's what everybody has.
I mean I wouldn't repeat the stories can,
wouldn't want to get anybody in trouble,
but they're mostly just coke
and naked people stories.
Funniest one I ever heard was Tj Miller.
That comics,
he asked for either an actual or a picture
of opinion in the green and so like
sometimes the promoter has to like
draw the picture of opinion. I'm like,
that's awesome. I wish I've, I've
gotten nothing exciting on there.
But until recently there was some mistake.
We're told drivers not to look at me or
not to talk to me like something was in
there and in December I heard
that and I go, oh my God,
that's not supposed to be there.
Please take that out. And they haven't,
I just found out they didn't.
So it's cause I'm always like,
why is there such horrible tension in
this on this ride? And then they're like,
they're like, and I'll talk
to them, they're like, oh,
you know what says some nuts.
And I'm like, oh my God, that's so
embarrassing. Like me being like, no,
don't talk to me.
I've had that in my rider accidentally
as well. Not even accidentally.
Like it was a conversation that
somebody must have had someone like you
shouldn't talk to him. It's like,
what are you talking about? Like that.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I used to be really pained by small talk
actually like on the road because you
have so many little interactions.
But,
but Colin Quinn like really
turned me on to small talk.
He goes so hard and the small talk
that like people go the other way.
Like he just like an art form to him.
He won one driver at a time.
One person who works at a hotel,
like he just,
he'll small talk you to death and it,
and it really has,
it really has like sorta
changed the road for me. Okay.
I've had some great drivers. I had
some really, really hilarious dues.
I had a dude in New Orleans that grew
up in New Orleans and it had no idea how
New Orleans was in relationships
I've ever been in. Yeah. And,
and in comparison to
the rest of the country,
like there's certain things you just
get away with a New Orleans like walking
down the street with an open beer. Like he
was, the cops pulled him over, he was a,
and he was only like, you know, a
couple hours outside of New Orleans.
He said he drove a couple hours
and he's out there with a beer,
like sitting there,
a bias car drinking this beer and the
cop pulls over and the cop starts asking
him questions and while the cops talk and
tell him he puts the one beer down and
cracks open. Another one, oh my God.
And like nothing starts drinking the
second beer. And the cop was like,
are you out of your fucking
mind? Like what are you
doing? He goes, wait a minute,
the car goes, where are you from? And the
guy goes New Orleans and he's like, oh,
okay, listen, you can't do
that here. Right. You can't
do that anywhere else. Yeah.
You live in a crazy place.
Such a cultural, I love it there. That's
my, that's also my favorite place.
But I've seen, I've seen the worst stuff.
They're the worst, the worst violence,
the combination of everything bad.
And I went to college in Baltimore,
like e not a coincidence that
they filmed the wire there. Uh,
but in New Orleans,
I was like 17 I was her and a volleyball
tournament and I was in a hog and Nas
and I saw these two guys
straight from the by you.
And they were talking,
they were both like hitting on this
girl and they didn't know that it was a
hooker and they didn't know that it was a
guy, you know, and it was, I was like 17.
I was like, Ooh, that's dark.
And they were both like celebrating
that this hot girl was talking to them.
And I was like, oh, one of them is about
to catch a deck. That's hilarious. Yeah.
That happened. I love
that city. It's like,
yeah. A friend of mine wants to California
and my friend Eddie were in, um,
we were right by the comedy store,
you know that hotel by the comedy store,
that ramp that's going up. Yeah.
And this woman was driving up the,
up the hill and my friend Eddie was like,
to that check is so fucking hot.
Oh my God, look how hot
that girl is. Yeah. And uh,
she was a transvestite who
had a transsexual that had
done a piece on the man
show with us. And I said, oh, I know her.
And I'm like, she's a, he. He's like,
no fucking way. I go, well, not anymore.
She's not. Yeah, she used to be,
I guess she's still kind of is because
she has a penis till. Yeah. What was it?
A transsexual.
A transvestite.
Transsexual is someone who
has gotten their sex change.
Transvestite is someone who's
dressed, dressed as a woman. You know,
you could be a cross dresser too. Yeah,
he's kind of weird when you defined,
you know like what they are like what did,
what did,
what does a person who dresses
like a wall? Norton fuck them.
But I mean not even if they,
I mean not even like a sexual thing cause
if it address like I think you can be
a transvestite and be completely uh,
heterosexual
like Eddie Izzard I think just
cross dresses or he did anyway,
but doesn't like it very straight I think.
I don't know. You know, I, I don't
know why he did that, but it worked.
Whatever it is, stop. And it's obvious
that he's got talent outside of that,
but whatever it is, he worked. He um,
he did an amazing thing once
where he ran around Europe.
Did you ever see that documentary?
No.
My respect for him shot through
the roof. See, that annoyed me.
I don't even know anything about it,
but him doing that,
like it makes me feel lazy
and right away I'm like,
you don't have to see it to
understand what he did. Um,
because it was incredibly impressive.
It was, I guess it was on the UK,
on TV and it didn't get on TV in America.
You've got to watch on the Internet,
but he ran like every day
run a marathon and yeah,
he ran all around Europe.
It's the saying what he did was insane.
It also does is act like an Arabic.
He does is acting like a bunch
of different languages. Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Tell him whatever he does it and he's
a bad motherfucker. That guy's amazing.
He ran around the fucking, I mean he's
not an athlete. This is the thing.
He didn't do it when he was in shape. He
did it when he was fat. He just did it.
He just forced his body to do it.
He finished a 1,100 mile
marathon around Britain
and that's exactly so right away. You
like just respect that cause, right?
Oh my God.
Are you running from what you're trying
to escape from and maybe that's my
defense mechanism. No, I don't think he's
doing escaping or running from anything.
He did it all for charity and he was,
he had a goal.
You set this goal in his mind and he just
decided to try to complete this goal.
What was the traffic charity?
Jamie, does it say sports?
Eddie is finishing. I don't know.
I don't know. He looks great.
That might just be a website that
sponsored it. There was some,
some aspect of it was
a related to charity.
How his body transformed
during the time he did it.
He ran a hot shit and fucking miles,
but like he had the most
horrendous blisters on his feet.
I mean his skin was torn apart on his
feet just because his body was just so
unused to this.
I mean that's something you could try
just trying to build up to running a
marathon. Just a marathon. A,
that's how fucking serious
physical undertaking 26
mile right now. I'd be like,
whatever the charity, I couldn't do it.
This guy did a hundred of them. I mean,
Jesus Christ, it means how many
[inaudible], how many did he run?
30 or something like that. 43 marathons.
They didn't even put it on TV and all.
We're all of them. A standard marathon
rate of 26 miles. Is that what it is?
That's a marathon. 26 miles.
Yeah. That's incredible.
Is that the youtube video
or like a website? No, there
is a youtube video of it.
You could watch the whole thing every
step of the way and there was parts of it
where he was running really,
really, really, really slow,
but he did not fucking quit. It's
incredible. Like you, you know,
you just look at this guy pushing himself.
His knees are falling apart,
it's feats falling apart and he just
gets up there and he just fucking keeps
running. I just think I can't, I can't
help it. I'm like, what's he running from?
But why is he running from something
if he's trying to accomplish something,
accomplish something.
Right.
Like you don't want to date anybody
that shows up at the gym at 6:00 AM like
come on crazy motivated and wanting
to take care of yourself is one thing.
But then I think something that insane.
I mean if it's the raise money
for charity, like why don't you do
stand up and they'll put
that on TV in America.
You got a goal,
set a goal to see if he could pull it off.
I think we have to agree to disagree
cause like I don't think it's cool and I
like him and like I think he's
really funny and so I, I feel bad.
No look you've got a point,
you've got a point.
I mean why not just ask people to donate
the money or donate the money yourself
or you've got a point.
I mean,
but not like, I mean of course
then why even have a fundraiser?
But I'm just saying to do
that. Ah, I don't know.
I know zero about it except what you've
just told me. But, but it right away.
That's what I think.
Well, so here's the, here's another
optimistic way of looking at it,
or positive way of looking at it.
He's also on top of what he's doing.
He's inspiring people because what he did,
it's skin is an incredible accomplishment.
Yeah.
Running 1100 miles or whatever
the fucking room hire you to do.
What did you inspire me?
Do anything inspire that feeling in me.
I wanted to fucking,
I don't even know what the charity is.
You just thought like,
well,
you just appreciate humans like doing
amazing shit and I just don't like, yeah.
Every year. The marathon. No,
but I really like going down to the
marathon in New York and like rooting.
So like, everyone's so excited to like
really emotional, but I'm like, you know,
do you give a shit about the Olympics
when the Olympics come around? I,
I not the Winter Olympics, I just cannot
give a shit about the winter Olympics.
But I liked the, I liked gymnastics.
I get into some, some Olympics.
You know, what's the biggest tragedy
in all sports? Is that the Olympics?
That they don't pay the athletes.
Oh,
I thought it was like duping
amounts of money. No, the those are,
those are professional athletes.
You know,
the idea that they're amateur
athletes is fucking preposterous.
The amount of revenue that gets generated
by their athletic performance as
fucking staggering. Wait,
because it's so much. Yes.
It's an incredible amount of
money. All of them, right.
It's an incredible amount of money
that the Olympics itself generates.
The Olympics itself.
When people are watching the Olympics,
there's fucking millions of
people around the world. Untold,
millions watching at the same time,
and the advertising revenue
revenue is stupendous. I mean,
they must make unbelievable
amounts of money, right?
It costs a lot of money to put it on.
It's not a free event,
but the amount of profit that is
generated by the Olympics must be fucking
phenomenal. Yeah. It's an excellent
opportunity for young athletes. You know,
it'd be more excellent. Pay Him
Bitch, give them some fucking money.
He's not a little money either.
I'll a shit ton of money
they have.
They throw away their entire childhoods
and then like one of them makes a lot of
money and like there's like a dozen
girls never getting their period.
There should be something you
could watch them for a week.
There should be some sort of scale,
you know,
where a certain amount of accomplishment
leads to a certain amount of revenue.
Yeah.
Yeah. Cause that's the thing, when
you're younger you're like, Oh,
if you make it to the Olympics,
you're just rich.
Like I thought it was like hunger
games and you were like a victor.
You just like when so much money. Right.
But really it's like why even ballerinas?
I'm like,
oh my God.
Only like a handful of you make it where
you can make a bunch of money still
you're just beating your body to,
to a pulp.
But then a lot of them like never
even get there and make no money.
A lot of them. Right? Like
what's the number? I don't, um,
I don't know.
I talked to a ballerina last season
of my show and she said like,
if you're starring in a ballet,
if you're like the New York Ballerina,
you make like I think under 500 a year
and that's the best ballerina.
But this,
I dunno how much scrolling do Olympic
athletes actually make some money.
Okay. It does say they do. This
is the, the actual numbers,
the Olympic Committee awards,
cash prizes to Olympians who
when a metal $25,000 for a gold,
$15,000 for silver and
$10,000 for a bronze,
but the money is considered earn income
abroad and subject to Irx taxation.
So when you win an Olympic gold
medal, you went $25,000 which is, hey,
so depressing. That's an, that's a,
you know, hey, that's a good wage.
If you're,
I'm a fucking burger.
That's horrible.
It's an unbelievable that you,
that you're like the person
that they're like, okay,
now like Nike or somebody wants
to, exactly. You'll get sponsored.
You'll be sponsored by
several different companies.
You'll make some money off of that.
And you know,
maybe you'll be able to
do seminars and shit.
25 you get the gold. I talked
to a model fuckers. I was like,
what am models make like are they just,
but the ones at the very top of the
game of course are making tons of money,
but like really beautiful chicks that
are working models make around that.
Like they make like maybe 50 grand a year
from what I've heard.
My Buddy's dating this
chick who is a model
and he calls me at all in quotes.
She's, she's like a real model,
doesn't advertise in campaigns and she
makes some touch to make $6,000 a day,
$15,000 in a day.
She's made as much as $25,000 in a day.
Just posing. She's not
famous. She's young. Yeah,
just stupid amounts of money.
Um, I think it varies is
what I'm trying to say.
But even like trying on a big campaign,
I think it varies,
but I know only like three models.
But they, they work and they,
they've gotten a campaign here.
There they are on the runway.
And it sounds like once
it's like a corporate,
like once in a while they'll make a,
they'll have a pretty good pay day,
but it's not consistent
and it's not that much.
It didn't sound like that
much to me for being hungry
on some of them isn't it?
It's just they can do it naturally.
Like some of them don't
have to struggle as much
like weight loss, body shape, that
ectomorphic body shape. Like the,
honestly I've only talked to three models
because it's not fun to be around that,
but uh, but they, um, even if they're
like naturally pretty thin, they still,
before doing that stuff
had to do liquid stuff and,
and uh, what's the thing where you
shoot salient in your, in your,
in your butthole, she'd
salient. Oh, that thing.
What do you are you're
talking about an enema? Oh,
I thought it was like a treatment or
something you do before you make me do
before the show. This place
seems that clean. That's
clean it. Trust me. It's just,
it looks rustic. Oh, I love doing his
punk ass, but he's always giving me
weird,
pulled through the same issue.
You're ready?
What did,
what the fuck is it about anybody?
Like why would anybody get really hung
up on the idea of incredibly skinny
people were in their clothes? I
don't know, but it looks good.
But what I've heard is
that it's like a hanger.
That's the idea that you want them
almost built like a hangar. Well,
I just had a fitting
today and it was like, um,
with someone who knew what they were
doing, which I haven't had that much of,
you know,
and she told me that it's all about
proportion because like a lot of people,
they think that I'm like actually
bigger than I am. Like people,
I'm a size six and people and what that
means like bigger than a four smaller
entity anyway. But um, but
then they've been like,
there's some websites or whatever
cause you can like be like,
what's her bra size or what's her
size and come back and be like, yeah,
I think there's like websites that say
I'm like a 12 or something, but whatever.
But anyway,
it's all about proportion and not,
and not really about how big
or small somebody actually is,
but these models that do the best
that the clothes look the best.
It is like a hanger.
They're like basically frail up
here and it looks but close look,
all clothes look dope on them,
but there's only like a very small
amount of of checks that you can,
you can work with.
I think there's also a very different
feeling that a woman has when she looks at
another woman than a man has when he
looks at a woman as far as like what looks
good and what doesn't look good.
Girls do that.
Girls think look good.
They'll dress or certain things
that they'll buy purses and shit,
especially to impress,
impress a guy with a purse,
but women are like real.
Some of them are like really into
purses to impress each other.
I like shoes, purses,
jewelry. I know nothing.
I don't have that. Like I'm
missing that. I'm just like,
no. I think I can be like, oh,
that girl like looks great,
but I don't even aspire to try
it because it seems so out of my,
out of my range. Um, but I can
look at a girl and be like, wow,
she's beautiful, but I'm
not like, oh, like, let me,
I wonder what she looks like naked.
You know,
obviously because I'm
not attracted to girls.
I sound like I'm like defending myself.
But, um, but it's so weird to me,
but I understand it cause I feel
like when someone's really thin,
like all the things that
we want to do naturally,
like eat and fuck and everything,
we like celebrate people that
are able to abstain the most from
that. Like, like, like, Oh God,
she really knows how to starve
herself. Or, um, like, yeah,
like she's just,
we sort of like celebrate people
just keeping themselves from biology.
That's a big one for women to write. The,
the ability to abstain. It's very, um,
it's like, uh, it's a badge of
courage or something. It's like, no,
I can't add a verbal, nothing
wrong. Well, why should you?
It's out of my wheelhouse. Good idea
that we're supposed to, it's so crazy.
The only problem with women is of course
if there's so many guys that are pieces
of shit and the men are more dangerous
in there physically in the pieces of shit
that you run into.
Yeah.
Whereas women are more dangerous maybe
financially in the pieces of shit that
you run into. What do you mean? Well,
you know, if a guy gets fucked over,
usually guys get fucked
over in a financial way. Um,
like divorces or they get
set up like I've seen it,
I've seen guys get set up
and it's very disturbing
guy with any money. Like I seriously
have never even dated. Yeah.
Guy I've met, um, I, I've, I've met
guys where I watched them go down,
like saw it happening.
They were not attractive.
They were uncomfortable with women and
they had all of a sudden this really hot
girl with them who likes slowly but
surely stocks are way in this position and
then bales with a of
cash. Then how like isn't the
transparent, don't these guys that are 80,
aren't they?
Why aren't they curious?
Like why this beautiful Kate Upton
look alike like is in love with them?
I'm suspicious of any guys better looking
than me that wants to sleep with me.
I'm like, what? Why? Like
what do you think I can show
you. I'm not gay. I'm Shim,
don't you? But don't you wonder? And
I know a lot of, I know not a lot,
but I know a handful of women that had
guys take their money because I think
women aren't to happen even
more susceptible to like
just wanting that love and
being like, sure. Joint checking.
I'll buy a house in our name.
Well, I don't think it's
mutually exclusive. I mean,
you can get ripped off no matter
what your sex is. Sexual preference.
I'm sure gay guys rib each other off
and gay women rip each other. Right.
As a matter of fact, I
know they do. I'm so like,
I know a gay woman who has to pay alimony.
My great grandma was a bootlegger
and she was always, yeah.
Her liquor store is still on 54th
street Schumer's liquors. Wow.
But she for street wear, um,
uh, in between park and Lex or,
or a male isn't like, yeah, it's
right across from monkey bar.
That is fucking awesome. What a
great story. But she um, she was,
she was just pounding it into
my head like that. Cause she,
I think her husband tried to steal money
from her, but she like put it away.
She's always like,
save your money.
Good for her. Yeah. You know,
it can happen. I mean you
get with the wrong person,
the wrong guy, the wrong girl,
whatever. That can definitely happen.
But I think that happens more with men.
Men tend to be the ones who have more
money in the relationships. I don't know.
I'm not saying that women do, they
make 70, I don't know what it is,
but whatever it is, I'm not saying
that women can't make money on,
don't jump down my throat. I'm
just, no, I'm not saying you,
I'm saying people out there on the
Internet. I wish that, I wish that
I've ever dated a guy. And then you think
[inaudible] steel. Yeah. I'm, I make,
I make a good amount of money now, you
know, and like, so it's weird like, yeah,
because guys are just like,
and I'm like,
Oh yes. Pass to. First of all,
I cannot pretend to be
interested in basketball and any,
I like going to games, but I can't, like,
I don't ever want to be like
wearing a jersey and being like,
I just don't want to do that athlete.
Do you know,
I still haven't been with a black guy.
Isn't that pathetic? Maybe I'm scared.
I'll be under the Detroit. You'll
be dancing. You'll, you'll change.
Start wearing beads. I'll wear a
Jersey is addressed. Big Hoop earrings.
Hardcore. We want to VH one reality
show. Like fighting with other chicks.
You'll, you'll be fine. I don't think
so. Change your personality entirely.
I had one encounter with a huge
deck and I talked about, um,
my last special I tapped out. I
was like, no way. Well, maybe,
I mean,
how many ways are there to use it go like
really big?
Like what are you supposed to do?
You just have to like stretch.
Yeah. I was like, I'm not,
we're not gonna have a life together.
I'm not going to power through this.
Or you change your shape.
How about stretches out?
Just like when a woman has her breasts?
No, regular plus super athletes.
Probably constantly horny. Oh my God,
no. Are the, our athletes is
known as being oh yeah, for sure.
I would imagine.
I'm never in a relationship where it's
like I have the same sexual appetite is
the guy I'm dating.
It's either like they are like wanting
it too much or it's me wanting it too
much. Like it's, I've never
really had it even out of you.
Yeah. Yeah. Where it's been like
that's good. That's encouraging.
It definitely happens. It's hard.
Think it's way harder for a check.
I mean I'm just guessing. I
think so. Cause it's what?
I don't know if like if your girl is like,
no,
not tonight. Does it like
hurt your feelings? Are you
like what's wrong with me?
Or you're just like, uh, no he
doesn't want to or whatever.
But also you've been,
you know,
if you're with somebody for
a long time it's different.
I don't think there's any reason why,
you know,
two people can't figure out that they're
not sexually compatible and if you
start dating each other and you'd get
to a point where you're like spending a
lot of time together and then
you hit those, that thing.
Whoa,
okay.
We're figuring out what's important here
because there's a bunch of shit that's
important here.
The big important one is caring about each
other and having a good time together.
That's the number one, right?
That's number one.
But number two is you like to fuck each
other and if you don't put it at number
two, what are you putting in? Number two?
Yeah. What is there? What's number two?
Financial security mean? What?
Is it a coexisting interest? No,
I have almost nothing co
interest with my wife.
There's not one thing that she likes up
a few TV shows and some art things and
some but her off her hobbies,
like things that she enjoys to just her
things and then you know, we, we hang out,
we have fun together.
Like you don't have to have the
same mutual desires or the same,
you can not have to be
into the same sports.
Like I've actually heard guys say that
they would never date a girl that doesn't
watch sports because the last thing
you want is her complaining when you're
watching sports. Fuck that. She doesn't
watch sports. I don't want to date him.
Yeah, I haven't seen on the, on my show
tomorrow night about that. Oh really?
I'm not trying to work
it in. It's called, um,
Chica can hang and I just want to
tell you about it, but it's, yeah,
it's guys sitting around, they're
like, I just want to go like, oh,
she'd like a lantern jaw and like really?
Like she does my fantasy picks and then
you realize they're just describing
dude's like, it's just, but I mean I know,
I know girls that are are real
into sports but, and I'm not,
but the difference is I'm, I don't,
I don't care about sports at all,
but I'm not like,
and I don't want you to like I'm busy
and I'm psyched to do my thing and I have
my interests and like please do you,
I saw a tweet once where girls are the
girls who were into football get bigger
diamonds,
Twitter pictures and like
a bunch of people like
retweeted it and I think it was
like a girl, like a sexy football
outfit on or something. You know,
that's so awful.
And I feel like that's like the image of,
that's like what girls see and
even I've been going cause um,
the NBA is like a big part of this
movie then I'm going to do okay.
Oh Shit.
What did I say?
Amy Gets on Black Dick
Photo first time shit.
I don't even know if I was on outstanding.
Oh, don't say it didn't happen.
But anyway,
nobody remembers on the Internet.
But anyway, like you
know, seeing these, uh,
just seeing the way women are represented
on TV, like all these real housewives,
like no one's doing. Even if they're
like, oh, we had like this luncheon for,
for charity, like good, whatever.
The thing that's getting edited and what
we're seeing is you guys being monsters
and like this is these shows. This
is what girls are seeing. Like,
I don't have any, I know jewelry, like,
I don't know the girls that I'm close to,
no one cares about a handbag.
No one, no one gives a shit.
But that's not the girls that you see
on television. They're all comics.
They're all like, oh, see
they're all Rachel Feinstein,
Nikki Glaser.
Oh yeah. You're all a bunch of artists.
You're all trying to be comedians. If you,
if her comic like all of a sudden became
incredibly obsessed with keeping like
an upstanding or attractive appearance,
that would immediately preclude a
lot of the comedy. Yeah. You know,
because you weren't, you
wouldn't be relaxed at all.
You'd be like such a, you're,
you're inciting like a a look,
a way of someone looking at you
like look at Harvard there pag. Mm.
What did that dress probably
costs a lot of money.
Leave the people care about
that stuff and it's not,
I think I'm better than that.
It's honestly insane to me. It's,
it's insane to me that anybody would
put value on like just that it's so
transparent. Like look, this is expensive.
Like I just, I think that's so cool.
Totally right.
But let's play devil's advocate.
What if you are just really
into beautifully crafted things,
whether it's a watch
or whether it's a car,
whether it's a purse isn't impossible
that it couldn't that I see that a lot of
people,
I believe you're right,
a lot of people there watching that
stuff and they're looking at different
people that have different
things and they want to show off.
They want to show everybody that they've
got the purse that costs x or the shoes
that cost. Why are all my God look at
the size of the rock she's got, right?
There's certainly people
that won't do that,
but isn't it possible that there's
other people that could just enjoy a
beautiful purse or enjoy a beautiful home?
I also haven't,
I haven't like seen that.
I don't know anyone with really
expensive stuff. So if someone was like,
look at this,
watch it costs 20 grand,
like I've never seen that and maybe
I'd be like, wow, that's amazing.
I'm about comfort. And like
I like traveling, you know,
I like, my bed is expensive.
Like I like, you know, things that
sort of lend themselves to experience,
but I haven't seen, but you know what, if
you have so much money and you're like,
oh I want to get this beautiful
thing. I understand that. But I,
I do know a lot of dudes that are like
posting pictures of their possessions.
They got Instagram. Yeah. And I'm
like, yeah, it makes it like, oh,
come on. Like you don't have to do that.
Well that's the, some dudes have to,
but why, what is it, what does that mean?
Well, they don't have to, of course,
I don't think it's rappers. It's like
rappers are like, I got this, you know,
and the obviously I actually love hip hop,
but that was the lyric. I just want to,
I've got this like I don't,
that's obviously not what
they say, but it's, you know,
it's like a lot of it is like about
about how much your passions
showing your shit off,
going on to dub magazine
cover with six cars. And Yeah,
of course that's part of that culture.
So I think that's what,
that's where that comes from. It's
like, it's like attached to you,
you just ego and just like alpha.
Well it's also a culture that's rebounding
from periods of extreme slow like
slavery, extreme poverty. Like there's
generation after generation of,
of negative things. The
racism, the riots, the, the,
the civil rights movement.
Like all those things are so recent.
It's hard for us to even wrap our heads.
Oh, it's so recent. It's humiliating.
We're so white to, no, we
don't, we don't feel it.
But I have friends that are half black,
half white. I have friends that are black.
I've, I've seen the differences
in how people react to them.
And it's fascinating to watch.
Yeah. You know, like big,
dark black dudes gets treated with fear
everywhere they go. It's hilarious. I
that that really is upsetting.
I,
I never really paid that much attention
to it cause like a couple of my best
friends growing up were black now.
There were no,
they were black and like I never really
thought about it until like going on
auditions because the sign in sheet would
be like for the whatever Susan and I
sign in and then it's like drug dealer
and then it's just like these black guys
are coming in, they're like
signing in. And I'm like, oh man.
Like this is just what, what a
society has done. They're like,
this is how we see you. Like these
guys were great actors. It's like, hmm,
someone's got to play the drug dealer.
Wouldn't you want to be a great actor?
You want it to be some real drug
dealer with the fuck you trying to say.
You liberal bitch. No. We had this
last season on the show we had a guy,
he was a mugger.
Yeah.
And the,
and in the scene it was called skip
therapy and it's a really funny scene.
It's like, um, and Kyle done again,
the common cause in it and uh,
and this guy like steals my bag and we
needed it to be a stunt guy. And so, but,
but I forgot that. So the guy who
came, he was as great stunt guys names.
Actually Muhammad Ali was actually,
it wasn't him, but that's his name.
And he came and I was like, I was like, we
cast this black guy as the mugger. Like,
are you serious? They were like, no. Like,
he's like really great at marsh
lords and stunts and stuff.
The best is when you have a,
a white mug or that doesn't look like
a mugger at all. Yeah. And you're like,
Oh God,
I hate when shows do that.
I felt like there's some shows are,
they're like,
the guy steals the purse and you're like,
oh my God,
never has this guy been run before.
Yeah, I'm sure. Yeah.
I don't think we could ever even wrap
our heads around what it would be like to
be discriminated against solely basic,
you know,
just completely based on the way you
look and to have it feel like that's
insurmountable. And then once you do make
it and you, you know, but you get big.
I could see all the,
the braggadocious behavior
being like exuberant, exuberant.
That's not a word. I made it up
because it sounds good though.
Jubilant exuberant people.
People look at it.
Me, I like just getting onstage, you
know, just like my first, whatever,
like 10 years, I feel like it was
like, it's like, ah, this bitch.
Like I look like I'm
going to be a dumb bitch.
I know.
Like, oh crazy. You do not
look dumb. I look like I'm
going to be a dumb bitch. Yes,
I do. You saying dumb bitch meaning
just a woman or you like dumb white.
You think you'd look them?
I think I look like I've,
like if I saw me in like
a mall, I'd be like, Eh.
Oh my God.
That's so funny.
I mean like, well you people have
known who you are for so long,
but do you like how did people like
I look like a meathead for sure. Yeah.
I just like past you. I'd be like,
but I have a lot of meathead tendencies.
It's like it's a rational,
a prejudiced to think of me as a,
I mean I'm fucking cage fighting
commentator for God's sake and I am a dumb
bitch and I'm a dumb bitch too. I
consider myself a silly bitch. But
I mean there's,
but the problem is that we have this idea
that everyone is so different and then
these people that are so
different can't be friends.
Like I have friends who don't work
on ever. I mean Brian is my friend.
Brian is like just started working out.
I feel like for years he just started
working out and smokes cigarettes
constantly. It's totally unhealthy. I
mean just stops. Like he's not like,
well my point is like I'm not like a,
it's not like I can't hang out with
other people that don't fucking live.
Would you like to watch fighting? Like,
I don't, my friends are all different
that, I mean like I know you're in shape
and whatever, but that's not, well,
but I mean I've also spoken to you,
but I don't know if I
just like walk past you.
I don't, I think it's just, it's
easy to pigeonhole people. Yeah.
And I think there's a lot of us that are
a combination of things and that's the
people who have been most fascinating to
me when I meet someone and I think that
they're, you know, I prejudge for
whatever reason and think, oh,
this person's probably this.
And then it turns out that they're like
a combination of things that I've never
even met before. Yeah.
Those are the greatest.
When you meet someone that doesn't fall
in any category. Yeah. And you get to go,
oh,
I have misconceptions.
And then like this person is just a
unique individual completely on their own
little trip and cool to see.
And then the APP that runs in your
database and now your spectrum sort of
broadens a little bit your ideas.
That's one of the things that I think
one of the reasons why people get in like
so many shit relationships because
their spectrum is like super narrow.
They've only had like a narrow band of
people and the type of experiences have
been like really similar and
negative over and over again.
But other than it just being a
specific like type, you know,
socioeconomic,
that kind of stuff.
Don't you think it's just like those
patterns that were set up just real early
on just from your young shit?
It definitely can be for sure.
You also get it from your
parents I think plus and minus.
I think some people see their parents
involved and like really negative
relationships and they completely changed
their gears and they just reject it
like from the jump and then they don't
take any shit from anybody that all
anybody fucking turn them into
a doormat. Totally. Either or.
It's either or sometimes.
Yeah. Yeah. I do that. I do the, um,
I do the former. Yeah, of course.
That's where your calm, oh my God,
you can't give me the love I need and
you're a narcissist. I'm like, come here,
come here. I'm like, yeah, comics.
That's part of the whole reason why I
became comics is because we had a whole,
yeah,
who were trying to shove some funny in
their stuff up that hole and anybody who
doesn't have that whole guess what?
You're not funny.
Yeah. I just get you just get a
Harris fact that you did that.
Yeah. I think it was only 46 to give
them more credit than he's doing.
I mean anybody can do 46 oh my
God. Yeah. I think you can't,
you can't be a comic
unless you're on balance,
but I think somewhere along
the line you can be balanced.
At least I like to believe so that you
can balance it out. Yeah, you can. Right.
The ship just got to
figure out like what is,
what are your like as far as like your
psychological needs and how do you meet
those? How do you, how do you maintain a
good psychological existence? Like, yeah.
I feel like I'm getting healthier. Yeah.
I hope I feel like that because yeah,
you're more successful so
you're more relaxed too.
That's got a benefit you a bit.
Um, I'm, I am more relaxed but
I don't, but it's just, yeah,
I'm just like less stressed by some
things but I am having like sort of more
pressure on me. But I think it's
just like showbiz pressure. Yeah.
I think it's just like taking a step
back and keeping the people close to you
that will tell you like that was
stupid or like you like dog shit.
Just people who keep it real. So
I have like people I trust. Um,
and you keep it real
for yourself too. I mean you can tell
you you're constantly questioning things.
And do you worry about that though?
Because that is an issue
with a lot of people.
People worry about becoming famous and
awesome going cuckoo cause we've kind of
seen it Nina.
Yeah, definitely. I
I've I I do worry about,
cause I you get so like
every day I feel like you,
somebody like slaps you in the face.
I,
the way I started going out on the road
was on the last comic standing tour and
we have to do meet and
greets after every show.
And sometimes it was like an
arena would be like 3000 people,
however many you would wait
and they voted for some people.
So some would come over to me and be
like, my husband likes you, but I know.
So I just like got used to and it was
like 40 cities or something and I just got
used like this defense. It's just
like built into me now. So I'm like,
I've been like trying to break down,
forget it. My childhood insecurities,
like what happened is the first
times I went out on the road,
so I'm afraid of my defense has got so
built up that I had to really like break
them down so that I could
sort of let the right ones in.
But I am afraid that my defense is,
we'll get too strong because you'll see
like really famous people that are like,
your idols are comics you love and you
meet them and they're so disappointing
because there's so withholding
and it's like you're like, yeah,
it's probably because they've been
wronged by so many interactions,
but you still can't
let that happen to you.
And so that is something that I am aware
of and I don't want to let happen to me
because I am, I am like,
you know, afraid of,
of somebody saying something or like
hurting. You're trying to take too much.
And you know what I think about
it with Louis, Louis C K when I,
when I first was interacting with him,
he was like kind of
standoffish with me and uh,
and he should have been because I'm sure,
I'm sure I wanted something from him.
You know,
just being a newer comic,
you see someone and you know what the
clubs like, they like, there's like,
you just have this urgency as a comic,
like, and you don't know what to do.
And like no one can tell you this
is what you do to be a better comic.
This is what you do to get work.
Even if they tell you,
just get on stage as much as possible,
you really can't hear it.
So Louie being so like sort of
guard with me, he should have been.
And now like we've a very nice rapport
and it's always good to see him.
And we talk and I, and I kind of like
resented him a little bit for being,
being cold to me at first,
but I'm like, I'm like,
he should have been because I'm sure
I even know what I wanted from him,
but I'm sure I wanted something
from him so I get it. But,
but also like you were saying before on
the air, like just, you know, somebody,
people will project stuff onto you if
they have like an interaction that's less
than satisfactory,
but it's not about you.
Like you can't change
anybody feels about you. So,
but whenever my long rant,
my point is just like,
I'm trying not to become an asshole and
to give people the benefit of the doubt,
at least like I'll go into
every interaction like hi.
And then if they say something to me that
shuts me down, then that's, you know,
I at least I went into it open.
Right.
I feel what you're saying.
And I think that that concern
is a good thing to have.
And it's cool that you're thinking like
that because we all need to learn from
the people that we've seen that
have disappointed us. Yeah. Yeah.
People that we've seen that,
you know,
just for whatever reason someone became
a prep because of camp famous. Yeah.
That's how I've been to a lot of
comedians. I've seen it, I've seen it.
And they stopped being funny too.
There's another weird thing that happens.
They get a little too famous, too
much adulation, too much. You know,
they have a sitcom or something
like that and then, okay.
Or they want, they want credit for like
their new art. They're doing like, look,
I know I was funny at one point,
but now I play the standing base
and like if you want to come see me,
that's what you're going to get. And
it's like, who does that? Well, I'm not,
I mean like it's not the standing base,
but I'm just saying, I think, cause I,
I even will have those impulses. Like,
I don't want to be funny right now just,
and you know, but you're like,
but then I'm like, bitch,
that's how people know you.
But wait, why don't you need a
podcast? That's what you need.
You always say that to me. Humor. You
need a God damn podcast because you can,
first of all, you really good at it.
You're very smart, very articulate.
You'd be fats and fascinating
and breaking things down,
but all those misconceptions would go
away. If people got to listen to you talk,
then you wouldn't worry about if people
knew you because you would have put it
out there. So many times there
would be like real clear,
but I'm not that worried about
if people know me. Right. But,
well, okay, I see your point. But you're
not really worried that people know you,
but your interactions,
like you're worried about
your interactions with people.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Okay. You just want to make sure
that they're as good as possible.
I want to like know that I did my
best and that I was open having a nice
interaction and, and, and making
small talk and whatever. Um,
uh, I don't, I don't know.
We know we're talking about like you,
you were saying you worry
about getting detached,
you worry about becoming one of those
people that's kind of, it gets goofy. Yes.
Running the podcast. Do you
like grounded? Oh, 100%.
Cause you get feedback all the time.
You're constantly get updated and check.
So you kind of,
I don't, but, but what, what, what's
the feedback good for? I mean,
and I'm on Twitter.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm on Twitter and I do think
you're right though. But, but then I like,
I don't think it's good to reinforce
pause. I'm negative feedback.
Like someone will, you
know, right. You know,
like you're disgusting and
then you look and it's like,
oh they write to famous people all day.
You just block them.
You don't have to wait. You
just block them. I just like,
I would never reward like that.
Well you don't, that's the
one to you about, I mean,
sometimes people will have valid opinions
about what you're doing stand up or
whether it's a podcast or whether it's
like the fucking upright tube or whatever
you do. Everybody, whatever.
It is every really funny everybody has,
you know, they're going to have opinions.
You're going to have opinions
and everything you do. Yeah.
Some sometimes having a those opinions,
like if,
if they're mostly swinging
to the right side, yeah.
They're mostly swing to the good side.
It gives you sort of a frequency
that you're, you, you know,
that they appreciate it.
You can do like tapped into this thing.
Like people love the Amy
Schumer show, boom, inside
Amy Schumer on comedy central.
Now Amy has a blog, you know, hey, watch
Amy do videos. I'm going to go do laundry.
You know, like you, you're,
you tap into your tap into,
uh, a certain vibe when you,
you get a certain amount of feedback.
Yeah. I, and I feel like
as a comic, you know,
there's that urge to communicate,
which I have.
But then there's also,
I think also as a girl,
as a bunch six and I and I talk like very
openly and then some of that feedback
it makes you like, oh, should I not be
sharing this much of myself because,
but then you're like, I'm like, no,
I've made a decision like I'm gonna
live my life this way and try and make
people laugh and maybe feel better.
Right.
But then like that sometimes that's met
with where you're like, is it worth it?
Cause this is so hard sometimes and,
and I'm not just like scared of
somebody saying something mean to me.
Like it's also people not respecting your
boundaries and, and it is, you know, it,
it's, it's like a struggle
and it is like, you know, I,
I do have to like kind of work and
be aware of not becoming like real
standoffish.
Well you're,
you're not really capable of filtering
who knows you once you become famous.
And that's a big difference between that
and just being an ordinary person going
about your day, especially an
ordinary woman going about your day.
Because so many men,
like with women,
take on an aggressive approach.
It's almost like it's,
it's almost commonplace,
right?
The guy just aggressively comes
up to girls and hits on them.
Women are just as aggressive,
I find sometimes,
but it doesn't come with the physical
threat. Oh, this feels like with a man,
right? Like if a chick's aggressive
with me, I'm always like, oh, okay,
it's a crazy bitch. I gotta
get Outta here. Yeah. But I
don't, I'll go, oh my God,
that what if she follows me into my car.
That is true. There is, there is
the added fun bonus of like, Oh,
this guy might try it.
I try to rape you. Yeah. I mean,
that's less fearful when you're a man.
I mean,
you're always could worry about
someone doing something to you.
Be honest with you. It's a real
bummer to know that you could be
sexually assaulted. I couldn't
even, I mean I can imagine,
but I couldn't, you know,
it's like I couldn't imagine.
I also couldn't imagine being pregnant.
It was a lot of things I could pretend
to imagine, but I really can't imagine.
I can't imagine not
drinking for nine months.
That's my Eddie Izzard marathon.
I'm like,
I have a couple of people drank
while they were pregnant for a year.
Some of the greatest people that were
ever created were created by people who
always says that she drank
through all four pregnancies.
What things you're allowed
to have a little wine.
I think like a small glass of wine is
actually good for your body and it relaxes
you and then I would be like,
if he wants to give a fuck,
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I bet you're not fun when the black
athletes, when you're doing that show
escort,
you'll have twins before you even know
if a year from now he come back
and I'm like, you've got twins.
I've got little half black babies.
Like the crazy thing is all
I did was check him off.
He came over and like to to the next
thing. I know I was pregnant. I mean,
I don't want kids. I take you to
court for alimony. They fucking right.
You don't need any money. They ran
through the lines in your crotch like,
like fire ants
move. They swim, they swim on land.
The fucking flopping around it. Yeah.
You're flopping around like those fish,
those snake fish that come out with those
snakehead fish that come out of water
and they walk on the land until they
find some new water or solar from the
Little Mermaid. No, a real fish. God
dammit. If you've ever seen that.
I saw the movie
is going to be three D so I was like so
psyched when they gave us the glasses,
I was like, what? It was like one of
the best surprises in my whole life.
I used to have Paranas allegedly.
Yeah. I had a bunch of them.
I used to feed them goldfish
allegedly. This is all fiction. Yes.
Many decades ago
when it was legal.
Yeah. The, that you could send
them into if you are an asshole,
you could put them in a lake somewhere
and they'd go in the non native waters
and they would wreck havoc.
And that's happened to a bunch
of different fish species.
Think this snake head was one of them.
Actually. Uh, if it's not the state kid,
it's different fish.
There's a walking fish is that it
invades in New York City
people through them.
Some people through these fish in the
pond that's in central park as cause they
thought it was funny.
And so now these things are living in
the pond and just destroying everything.
When I was there, I saw some
fish, some big giant fish attack,
something else in the water just to speak,
froth of water.
And then whatever it
happened, you know, happened.
It was like probably there's a
pond in central park, you know,
got a big pond in that water.
There's some crazy ass fish.
So this is, yeah, Monster Fish
in central park. Does it attack,
attack anything or can you just
see it? Oh, that's it right there.
He barely could see it. Yeah,
that's a snake. Snakehead fish.
Those things. He ducks, they'll
eat anything. Oh my God. They're,
they're like super hardy to like you.
Once you get them in an ecosystem,
you have to essentially kill everything
in that lake to get them all out.
What did they do? They just traffic, eat
everything and then become cannibals.
It says, if you see this
fish, it's like this,
see a terrifying fish with teeth and
central park. Kill it immediately.
It's too late.
The problem is these things are just
shooting out eggs and sperm and breeding
like crazy. This is like Predator,
like remember that movie Predator?
Like if Predator landed and just
started killing all the people,
that's what it's like for that thing.
Like that thing going into the pond
in central park. It's like, Woo,
let the party begin.
Such a bummer is there's a lion's.
A lion just got led into the fucking zebra
cage. The zoo. That's what it's like.
Oh.
I was like,
that happened or could happen and
that's what's happening with this fish.
It's just that's what it's like.
A Super Predator just got introduced
until this humble ecosystem.
We're about to film on that you might
watch murder behind you fish murder.
But the um,
the fish is like the worst thing you
could ever see for a creationist.
The fish walking on the ground
and walking to the next pond.
Cause if you're a creationist
and you see that you go away.
I mean don't creationists do that
all day looking at everything? Yes,
with denial. But this is one of
the most preposterous things ever.
Have you ever seen? You've never
seen one of these things walk? No,
I'm so grossed out and come here.
I leave upset because of the videos.
There's a documented from the Congo.
He got fucked by the horse that show that
outcome.
This is nothing nearly as disturbing.
But there's a video in the Congo where
I think it's prehistoric fish eaten by
dinosaur bird.
That's what it says.
There's this crazy bird called a shoe
bill and the shoe bill is like five feet
tall with an enormous beak.
It's beak is like a giant hatchet.
Yeah. It's beaches like he's,
it's beak rather is literally like
an ax on its face. It's huge beak.
And this bird is something
out of another era.
Like they used to be birds like that,
that like seven feet tall that lived
in North America and they don't fly.
They just sort of run around and
attack things and the predatory birds.
And why is it a bird like a penguin?
Penguins don't fly. You look,
we're birds were birds.
Bitch do not fuck
with us.
Did you see that dinosaur three d movie
that's available right now on Netflix?
I did not say, oh it's really good.
It's my first time. No it's not.
It's not animated and there
aren't that many dinosaurs in it,
but it's really worth it. Yeah.
This is not the dinosaur movie.
Donald Sutherland,
that's the dad.
He narrates it and it's like,
it's really good.
I obviously am psyched by three days.
Oh, so it's, it's a recreation of
like what they looked like. Yeah.
And they like got her
and dress her hairstyle.
Yeah. And it ends like spoiler
with a big, it's not a pterodactyl,
but it kinda looks like an ostrich.
Like it just looks like some sort of
like prehistoric sort of evolving bird.
That's like so awesome.
She just another good example of birth,
it doesn't really fly. Right. They don't
fly. They don't do shit to fuck you up.
They'll kick the shit out of you.
They fuck you did. I saw that video.
We try to fuck people. I don't, I think
I've talked about this in here before.
I remember being real traumatized by
seeing a guy laying there blindfolded and
he doesn't know what's fucking
him and it's an ostrich.
Well, that's not me. Never saw that. No.
Who would buy the times that happened,
I'd already given up.
I'm watching people get fucked by animals.
There was a certain time that Joe,
I'll tell you right now, I've done,
it was a certain time a few years
back where if you said, hey,
here's the link of guys getting
fucked by an ostrich egg in on it,
I would click it, but not today.
Today I'd be like, again, whatever.
I want to call your bluff
so bad you wouldn't call my
bluff because honestly you
don't know where it is.
I don't know if it was
something absolutely fantastic
where no one had ever seen
anything like it before.
Yeah. Then I'll click on it,
but I don't watch some dude
get fucked by animal done pass.
D u m the done.
Don't even try it.
You something like that starts up fucking
pinwheel and your head starts spinning
around. I have this guy here, we get to
that point. What did he start out as?
He used to be a baby one time.
What did his parents do to him?
Actually that's me watching any porn.
Well that's a problem.
I mean I'll power through it,
but still,
well I always looking at it and go out
and yeah, I'm going to fix them now. Yeah.
Two lessees with some Dick. God
has a plan. Yeah, you can't, um,
you can't fix them unfortunately.
But that is exactly how you should feel.
If you're a sort of a humane person.
Thank you. See them and you go, oh,
this poor people. Probably the victim. You
don't call them them. These poor people.
Yeah. These, can Paul call them these
poor people, those people, you know, um,
uh, for money. Give a fuck for money.
It's a weird thing that everybody
watches that, but nobody, uh,
nobody admits to it.
I will admit to the don't like to admit
to porn on it. That really watching it.
Yeah. I don't know anyone in my life that
doesn't, that doesn't watch porn. Wow.
Are you hanging out with different people
than me? Really? Well, I don't know.
It's a single dude who doesn't
watch porn girls, you know,
a lot of girls watch porn. All my friends
watch porn. Friends are all freaks.
But you know, know when I
was younger I was like, I
was, I did not like porn, like at
all. I remember I had a boyfriend,
I was like 23 or four, and I was
like, I thought it was like cheating.
And then I grew up and then you're
like, oh wait, this is awesome.
For a lot of guys,
23 is when that's the age cutoff.
So they don't get to
that new mature woman.
They just find another girls
and your porn. Oh, no, I really,
I know, I really like it. I have friends
that are like that though. Let me get,
the one girl gets to like 23 they
completely lose interest and they move on.
Again,
they're called Comedians,
but I think that grill comedians are
probably just completely different animal.
I guess if I had to guess.
I don't know.
I don't even think so. I don't think so.
I don't think I'm any wilder or crazier.
I think I'm probably like pretty boring.
But I,
you know like having sex,
like,
yeah, there's nothing wrong with
saying that on the radio or a podcast.
I don't know why. It's like, so why is
that a thing? I mean it's everybody.
It feels good. Like why is it,
it's okay to say you like massages.
People always ask me like in, you
know, like local press, they were like,
why do you talk about sex so much?
I'm like,
it's the most interesting thing
we do is people I think like,
why wouldn't I want to talk about, I think
it's like really funny. Why? You know?
And it's not that I think.
I think I'm probably having a like pretty
mundane sex compared to everybody else.
I'm pretty basic but just like that,
just hearing a girl like mention it just
kind of makes people like why I don't,
this is just judging by
doing like local press,
right?
Well you got to think about different
peoples look the jobs they have and the
amount of restraint that's required to
keep a job at an office where you're not
allowed to talk about anything
freaky for like eight hours a day.
I haven't had like an
office even before stand up.
I was just like bartending like are
you should fear but you're a woman,
you're a comic,
you know your,
your perceptions like why they
would be upset at you for,
for talking about sex or
liking sex because to them
it's like a mindblower like
she talks about sex all the time.
She just talks about like,
but it's not that I'm like,
oh my God,
I can't believe there's not
something in my body right now.
I feel like I have a totally normal
sexual appetite. Totally normal.
I think I probably watched
porn like twice a week.
The controversy is just talking about it,
talking about a sexual appetite at all.
That's the controversy.
I think even I just, you know, did some,
some shows on NPR and like they're,
they,
they've never experienced penetration
before. Like Sara Silverman,
when she did the ted talk
and they completely censored
or they pulled it down.
But that was about like a
kid being retarded. Right.
The Ted talk was,
I thought it was her act.
I thought it was like the joke and I'm, I
don't remember what the, let's find out.
We should find out since we're
talking about it. Sarah Silverman.
Ted taught called, yeah, I don't think
it was sexual. I think it was. Okay.
She's so sexual.
I don't think of Syrah is super sexual.
Oh my God. Are you kidding me? Her
Act. It's very sexual. It's very dirty.
It's hilarious. She's hilarious. Right?
Ted Versus Sarah Silverman
fight turns really retarded.
Okay. Uh, known for her shock and insult.
Humor was invited to give a Ted talk.
She subsequently trashed Ted Organizer,
Chris Andrew Anderson,
who tweeted,
I know I shouldn't say this
about one of my own speakers,
but I thought Sarah Silverman was God
awful. He wrote that and he's a bitch.
I'm real.
The problem was that Silverman kept
using the word retarded to fight Sarah
Palin's recent rant about the word.
The whole talk flew
right over the ted crowd.
So wow. That is hilarious.
Anderson deleted his tweet,
but silver men hit back today with
our own saying that Kudos to Ted,
Chris for moving Ted,
an unsafe for making Ted and
unsafe haven for all your,
a barnacle of mediocrity. Bill
Gates, asshole. That's awesome.
Oh my God. She crushed him. Yeah.
You're a barnacle of mediocrity
on Bill Gates' ass hole.
So good. Oh my God. That is beautiful.
That's Shakespeare. Oh my God.
That's so funny.
Yeah.
And then Steve Case weighted in AOL
founder Steve Case waded into the fight to
defend Anderson. He tweeted,
shame on you to Silverman adding.
The sad thing is you're not
that funny. Uh, you lose,
you lose this. We're staying
in that stupid. It's sadness.
Shame on you. You lose.
Unless you bring silly,
right? There you is.
Like if you say something to me and I say,
shame on you,
shame on you Amy Schumer or how dare
you, Amy Schumer. That's, I'm joking.
This guy is shame on you for real.
So when you say shame on you for real,
you're out, you lose, you're
out of the game's over.
The sad thing is you're not
that funny. Oh No. What? Okay.
You explained to me the whole Barnacle
on Bill Gates asshole line then.
Cause that shit is hilarious.
Line the fuck Outta here.
You know why that's not funny?
And Silverman's response was,
you should be nicer to the last
person on earth with an AOL account.
She got him to boom bitch,
the fight.
But she's Silverman in case continued.
But you get the picture. Oh,
that's beautiful. And good for her. Well,
that happened when they went after
salon.com went after Patton Oswald and he
crushed them.
Uh,
it's just so arbitrary.
There's just no,
you have no control over what somebody
picks up on what happens like that.
I mean, of course if you go on some rant
when you're like saying racist shit,
like that's ridiculous. But, but for
comics it's just, sorry, it's just,
it's just a slow news day and
they're like, this was a problem.
People just like choose
Norton. Um, after I,
people were getting really mad at me
about a joke I made about Steevo the sheen
roast
and Norton, he, uh, he like
stood up for me and was like,
you're selective outrage.
Steevo or the go died.
The joke was saying that I, that we
all wish that. Yeah, that was a joke.
They made the same joke
about, uh, about Jeraldo with,
with Anthony Jeselnik but it's a comic.
You're allowed to do that comics that was
on the road. Oh, I know. He's a comic.
Well, listen, I'm, I'm with
you. It's one of those things,
but hey,
with comedy,
it's always who's going to be the first
person to make the hike? You know?
And a lot of times I honestly didn't think
it was going to be like, you does it,
it's like,
it's like good to get an extra impact.
I honestly didn't think that was
going to be that big of a yikes. Wow.
I wasn't going for would.
I would definitely,
I wasn't going for the
headline on buzzfeed. I swear.
I would definitely think it would be a,
yeah,
like I don't know what the
fuck you were thinking, man.
I realize where I was really surprised
because it wasn't a big deal in the room.
It was like we're all hitting hard,
right?
Like I just didn't even think
that was going to be a big deal.
I just think that's comics.
I'm used to sitting around with those
guys at the cellar and it's fun.
It's,
it's how we communicate.
Tell you half of these guys who
were my best friends grew up, but I,
I'm ready with so many insults for them.
If one of the mocks back
wearing his stupid jacket,
Norton is awesome with that too.
Oh,
Norton has crushed me so many times and
talked about this funny story where he
was a,
he had a slice of pizza and Louis C K
saw him on the street and just slapped a
slice of pizza to the ground.
Called him a faggot
and he starts laughing when he's
telling the story. I was a juicy pizza.
Pizza too is a nice one.
You couldn't do that to
another person that you know,
they wouldn't appreciate that.
The humor in the inappropriateness
makes us so happy.
The other night we were
just playing Keith Robinson.
When he got eliminated from star search,
we were playing it over and over again
in front of him and by the way, don't,
don't think that you can come to
Amy Schumer's slapper pizza down.
That's not what we're saying. You have
to be a comedian. You know each other.
You still have a good friend,
but that's so funny.
Did you see a special roadwork
or it's awesome you can get it,
but it still happy that he's doing
well again. His show looks dope.
He's fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious.
I don't think there is a funniest guy
alive, but he's one of my favorites,
that's for sure.
But he,
I was sitting at the table with my rounds
of venture female comics and we were
all like eating dessert. It was like a
really like sad moment. He just walks up.
We're like, hey Dave. He's like,
oh, what are you guys having?
No boyfriend olive mode
like
that.
Like Tier Mizu saddest.
Uh Oh, that's so funny.
It's just like, oh boy,
Rick,
hey Dave.
He didn't even see us till he turned and
then just boom fired at us and Canada
just right off the cuff.
Boom.
He's definitely one of the best
joke writers out there. Yeah. Yeah.
He's got so much of his act as jokey
joke, joke, joke, joke, joke, joke, joke.
You know. So funny. Yeah. He's
hilarious. That skanks for the memories.
One of my favorite cds ever. So
good. Yeah, it's, it's a nice time.
Big Comedy Fan. Yeah. Lot of
good comics out there now.
It's just totally different experience
than it was 20 years ago I think.
I think a lot of it is probably
because of the Internet,
like more people have an avenue and
this is more demand for common and
I think just staying at some
comedy condos on the road,
they'll have like VHS is of old specials.
Yeah.
And a lot of them are pretty shitty. Like,
it'll be like kind of topical and, and,
and there is that like off the cuff,
like that movie punchline,
how ahead Sally fields
coming out at the end.
Kind of just like winging it and
like it working out as a comic,
that just set up a whole,
I think wave of people being like,
maybe I'm amazing at comedy and I don't
know it was, that movie was so bad. Oh,
the standup of that movie was so,
it was so,
so obviously not real
stand up. It was like, oh,
they were faking it and the audience
reaction was fake. You can't do that.
It doesn't work with standup.
Like you can fake being a fucking union
boss and screaming at the fucking people
in the yard. Yeah. But if there's
an artificial feeling to that,
it's not nearly as offensive as the
artificial feeling of watching Tom Hanks
kill it with nonsense. I was sober at
all. Like, oh, just you're just talking.
You could, yeah. You could see like he
probably could be a comic. He ain't,
he had good delivery, good setups.
Who's the, who's doing the prior movie?
I Dunno if they cast going to play
right your prior yet. But I was like,
wasn't it going to be Eddie Griffin
at one point in time? I Dunno,
but I hope it's a comic. It has to be. Uh,
I don't know. I would have to be, I mean,
I would think it would have to,
but even then it's not going to work.
One guy pulled it off ever. What?
Dustin Hoffman, Dustin Hoffman.
You ever see Lenny? No, it's fucking
brilliant. Yeah, it's fucking brilliant.
Yeah. It's fucking, he
like get ready for it.
But everything did he go on the road are,
and that's a really good question.
I don't know what he did,
but what he did do when he did the movie
is get Lenny Bruce Down to a fucking t.
Yeah.
It incredible.
I mean it was one of the best performances
of his career and very few people
know about it.
Yeah.
And very people outside of standups
even know who Lenny Bruce was.
Lenny Bruce or like bill Hicks collects
more, more people know who bill Hicks is.
Yeah. But Lenny Bruce is just
sort of a name, you know,
I could fucking Sid Caesar, you
know what I mean? All those names.
You don't really ever see the word.
Yeah. Red Buttons. Oh, that guy. Yeah,
I've heard of him. We don't sit around
unless you're like a real cool. Yeah,
I like it. That's something I like
to do on the road is going record
stores and listen to whatever comedy
albums they had. That's really fun.
It like, well, first of all
it's like sad that I'm like,
and then I'll do this today when I'm in a
city. Like there's a sadness to it, but,
but that, that sort, and it also keeps
me up because I, I feel bad. Like,
why is that sad? Um, I just think,
I think being stand up such like an
isolating life and so, but I like,
we'll be like,
I'm looking forward to like,
my couple of things I like to do
in cities. I don't know. I think,
I think everything about being a standup,
it's like sad. [inaudible] I think so.
Do you go on the road with other
friends? Um, well I have, um,
I have Mark Norman,
who's Hilarious,
opens for me or I have my friend Bridget
Everett actually now she like closes
for me. She's, she's hilarious. She's
a cabaret singer. But she gets naked.
Yeah. No one can follow
her. What does she do? She,
she does Montreal. She does. Um, she
does like, she'll do like the nasty show,
but she'll like have to close it because
she's, it's not stand up. She's a,
she's a singer.
She's like an amazing singer.
But she the one who does
with Hannibal Burress show.
She just did Hannibal show with
method man. It's Burress. Yeah.
Keep your hair. I wish, I bet you guys
were fighting together. But yeah, bridges.
I've seen her. I saw her, he
showed me a video. She's a killer.
So at first I just like want people
to see her. She does. She's the only,
like I do stand up on my show
and I'll do like an interview.
And the only time I don't do an
interview as if she's performing,
she's in a band with ad rock. She's
like such a bad ass, but I was like,
I just need people to see her,
Bridget Everett. And uh, so,
so she came on the road with me and
I was like, man, she's such a closer.
But then I was like,
I still want her to come out with me.
So I just like would do an hour and
then I'd be like, that's the show.
And I have a special guest and
I have her come out because she,
I feel like she changes people's lives
with how these actions is a performer.
You laughed so hard and it just, I dunno,
just like changes and there's, yeah.
Oh my God, that's awesome. And you
buddies in real life likes to go out
with my friends,
but don't you just have one person open
for you or you can get like, Oh okay,
that's nice. I've done three before.
I've done three. That'd be really fun.
We just, we got to get on a
bus this time. And it was fun.
Cause my Mark Norman has been opening
for me and he's, he's hilarious. Like,
but Bridget,
what she does,
she goes out into the crowd like
it's such a physical thing, but um,
she sits on dudes labs. She,
she'll motor boat. Anybody.
She air her,
her act is so killer.
Um, but it's been, but it's been
like so cool because um, yeah,
mark started opening for me like four
or five years ago. So the answer's yes.
You like to go on the road with your
friends as they make it less sad because
you're all just having a good time
together. Yeah, totally. Totally. Yeah.
That doesn't erase the 10 years
with a long time ago early,
I took a pay cut way
early to do that because
it's just too, yeah. And I would even get
grief by, they would say, well, you know,
across you this much to fathers first now
and that much to hire him and you know,
you're making this much less
because I'm like, so what?
Well, no, I got, I got my sister
traveling with me and my brother in law.
Like we have a camp,
we have a little camp and that's why
the road has been really sweet lately.
That's nice. It's fun. That's
definitely a good thing. Yeah. It also,
I find like I feel funnier when I'm
hanging out with all my friends cause we
were all laughing at each other.
Right.
And it keeps you down or you're
not going to be like, yeah.
You get what I'm doing.
Um,
Orlando on Thursday with
Joey Diaz nights or Friday.
Actually this Friday we leave
Thursday. But what's the, what's the,
it's going to be some theater, but we're
just going to have so much fun. Yeah.
I mean it's like,
I can't imagine not having fun hanging
out with Diaz all day and we're going to
have a great time. So I feel that all
day. So the road is like home, you know,
cause Joey's family and
we've been together.
We've been friends for
fucking forever now.
Longevity.
Yeah.
Joey will go to the gym and tell me
about it's fucking Jujitsu class.
Joey's going. Did you just do now
really kettlebell swings and shit? No,
he's just doing try and be healthy. Yeah.
Do a little exercise. That's awesome.
Yeah. He's uh, he's the most fun.
Yeah.
We have fun on the road.
The first time I did Orlando mark when
Mark Open for me and we stayed at this
hotel and it had a water slide.
Yeah. I was like Oh my God. And,
and it made me go do that club again
cause I was like well they've got that
waterside at that hotel
dude.
Waterslide there was a place in Phoenix
we used to do the Tempe Improv that her
water slide.
It was fucking awesome.
Yes. In comics, you know you're
getting, you're like, Oh God,
that club was super weird.
But the hotels good.
Like they do a free hour of drinks during,
okay.
You know what else has a water slide
is the hard rock in Florida at Florida,
Hollywood, Florida that me and Tate,
my friend Tate, we went that way.
We had to like a couple hours to kill
before our flight and we found out about
the water slide. The inner tube. Fuck Yo,
we wire slide if like two hours
before we had to leave. Oh yeah.
It was so much fun.
There were tunnels and shit.
You go shooting out the bottom
of the tunnel. Yeah. Good.
We were there the second time we went
back and there was a family and I guess
they were Muslim. They were
wearing burkinis. Oh my God.
Do you know this? That's real. Yeah. They
were all, all the girls were in Burkina.
It just, yeah, a bikini, but
it's a burka. Okay. Waterproof.
So that face is covered or their
whole bodies covered. It was there,
their eyes were out or their fees and
everything else was covered. Jamie,
pull up Burkini, Jesus Christ.
See this. That can't be real.
Yeah. And I was like, man, I want
that. Like why can't she just crying?
I would have gotten on the
waterside 10 more times and that,
that really literally freaks me out.
The chick look, so first of all,
the chick does not look like the people
that were at the water park with us,
but that freaks me. [inaudible]
name is like, Kelly, come on,
let's get this same Burkini.
That insane.
It's just,
it's insane that they look so happy,
but you're being cute.
But it's that culture,
like it forces that that's one of the
most insane things in 2014 that's it.
I mean, isn't that just fear?
I guess it's also a pattern.
It's a religious pattern. That religious
pattern, one of the left POW POW, pow.
The one of the right now all know
Jesus creating,
fixing that poor girl.
I went to Dubai once, her standup and
it was a real bummer. It's a bummer.
It's a bummer seeing people and you know
they don't think it's a bummer cause
they're used to it.
It's a bummer for you though.
If you have freedom to dress however
you want and you see something like that
and you just go, what's
going on? Why don't we,
the women like how come the men can wear
shorts and you could wear whatever the
fuck you want. Like the lion.
Can they though? I don't know.
I mean a lot love the men were religious
garbs as well. There could do what ever.
Whatever they want. Let ever, even some
of the comics I was working with was like,
some of them could say things
and some of them couldn't.
I feel terrible whenever I
see any form of suppression.
So when I see that that was the worst
thing was seeing the way that they dealt
with like the Filipino waitstaff,
just the people,
because it's such a caste system there.
It's like forget about the women being
that shield that it was like that was,
that was a bummer.
Well have you ever seen,
there was pieces that were done on some
unscrupulous employees or employers
rather that we're taking these
people from other countries.
They were getting them from like a,
a guy who'd be like a wrangler and he
would go to these other countries and tell
these people that they were going to
get a lot of money and tell these people
that all these good things
are going to happen.
And then he would bring them over here
to start working for these companies and
then they would take their
passports away and leave them.
These like subhuman conditions
is horrible conditions.
Sleeping like head to toe in a room with
22 dirt floors and holes in the ground
to shit in like vice did a piece on them
and you're like, this is incredible.
I mean,
it's not all establishments there,
but the fact that it does happen and
that the way it's set up, you know the,
I don't know who's responsible.
I don't know if it's the people at the
top where the people at the bottom that
are hiring these people,
like who's made the decision to
force these people in this situation,
take their passports away.
I don't know who made those decisions,
but that's all the awful,
but like honestly today I asked
for a decaf and like the chick,
I know there was caffeine in
that. You're being funny. Yeah,
there you go.
I just like it makes it,
when I'd hear things like that I think
of like, what's The dumbest thing today?
Twice I thought was
important. Oh, I see. Like I,
you know the things that I'll be
like, ah, this is, this is foam.
You called this foam Barista in
traffic on Santa again and you're like,
I'm Monica Boulevard is bullshit.
Man. Didn't say it was going to rain.
And then you're like, oh, you had to sleep
head to toe with people that don't pay.
Then you haven't seen your family
in 10 years. The stop light is down.
We have to figure out this
intersection on our own. When I called,
they said they had my size.
It really makes me feel like a monster.
Well,
it's terrible when you really stop and
consider how uneven the playing field is
from, from birth, from birth, death in
this, in this world that we live in.
Like you can get the
most awesome spot ever.
Like Amy Schumer and
be born in a nice city.
Nothing.
Dirt floors wasn't born to a rape camp.
You weren't born to some people in
India that's sold you to some government
because they need your money
that they're going to send back.
So you're working in some kitchen
somewhere. Some other country,
they have your passport,
you can never get home.
She's fucking crimes complaining about
having to learn how to make signature
cocktails while I bartended. You know,
that's a real issue of the passport thing.
They, they take their passports
and they can't go back,
which is just dark as fuck. That
is really dark. I mean, that's,
that's slavery. That's essentially like
you're not, I mean, there's no dogs,
there's no gates,
there's no guys with guns.
They let you send your saddest
amount of money home apparently.
But who knows. I mean, who knows
if that money even gets there.
If you can't communicate with your
friends back home or your family back home
and how are you communicating
with them if you're not,
if you are communicating with them and
it's free and uncensored, you'd be saying,
get me the fuck outta here. They have
been, they're holding me hostage.
Like just the people that get taken.
But there's also that's going on
where they didn't take their passport,
but it's the only way that they can send
money home. And it's voluntary, but no,
no doubt.
There's a bunch of different variables.
There's a bunch of different variables
when it comes to people that live,
you know,
if you are born in a third world country
or really poor village are really poor
neighborhood somewhere,
it's a fucking huge handicap.
Starting from there is incredibly
difficult. I have a friend,
his name is Justin Wren and uh,
he's been on the podcast before.
He used to be a UFC fighter and
then he went to the Congo and, um,
met these pygmies and he's become obsessed
with helping them and saving them.
So he,
uh,
he takes donations and he goes over
there and builds wells for them and helps
them and doers all sorts of personal
tragedies with them. He's gotten sick.
He's got some horrible
like Dang gay fever.
He almost died when he was over
there. I mean, like really horrible,
horrible shit to just to go over there
and try to help these people just because
he was over there and he just recognize
he had this feeling like, oh my God, like,
these people are so unhealthy and I
can help. Like I know I can help them.
So he just felt incredibly compelled to
make that like his life's mission to try
to help these people.
So really, um, there's,
there's some right now that's the pictures
of him with all these pygmy people
and so unbelievably touching story.
He's like the sweetest guy ever.
He was a fighter, fought in
the UFC. He's a very tough guy.
He was on the ultimate
fighter. And, uh, you know,
he's going through all this shit like
bullshit depression and you know,
alcoholism and you know,
all the problems that a,
a lot of people go through in this life
and found a new purpose when he went
over and met these people. You
feel susceptible to that. Yeah,
you can get definitely get
susceptible. What, which part?
I mean you personally like I could see
you getting real into a specific cause
but now that you would like your families.
Well I would definitely,
I absolutely could see myself
getting into a certain cause,
something along those lines,
but I just don't have the time to
dedicate to go over to the Congo and I
appreciate and respect that he does,
you know,
and I donate and I think that
donating to anything is a good cause.
Donate to anything where you can,
you know,
change people's lives like directly.
I think that's a good thing for you to do
with your time. I think no matter what,
if you can find something in life that
enhances your perspective on the world
because you've done something positive,
that's a good thing.
I think that's really what I got out of
what he did the most is that it really
truly enhanced his
perspective of the world.
He became like this really happy guy with
like a real mission and he sees like a
tangible result and all the care and
helped an aid that he gives these people.
It's just cool as fuck cause it's
so selfless and it's so, it's,
it's beautiful in that regard.
You know,
I think anytime we see something
like that, it elevates all of us as,
as a species.
You know,
I mean anytime you see someone who is so
selfless like that does something like
super, super positive. It just, it
elevates us as a species. You know,
that and that guy's just a awesome
example of what a human beings capable of.
It's cool.
And it's also fascinating thing that this
guy was like in the dumps and his life
was terrible until he started doing this.
And now he's like this really driven
happy person. He showed us pictures,
he's smiling and loves those people so
much. Why was his life in the dumps? Just,
you know, hard time. First of all, being
a fighter's unbelievably difficult,
very strenuous, very nerve wracking.
They're always nervous. They're always,
you know, forcing themselves
to get into unbelievable shape.
You're constantly disciplined because
you're doing strength and conditioning
work.
Then you go into a spar later that night
and then you wake up in the morning,
you gonna hit Mitts and then later that
night you're going to lift weights and
then the next day you're going to wrestle
and then at nighttime you're going to
kick box and then it's, it never ends.
It just keeps going and keeps going.
There's never enough fucking
hurdles to jump over.
There's never enough kettle bells to
lift is never enough myths to punch.
There's never enough bodies
to spar with. You keep going,
going, going, going, going,
going, going, and you red line
your body in a lot of ways.
And a lot of guys get depressed just
from that, just from overtraining.
That gets sick a lot.
They're exhausted,
but if you don't put
yourself through that,
then you get your ass kicked
and that's even worse. Yeah,
it's a lot of shit involved. And being a
fighter. We think being a comic is hard.
It's a choke. No, I mean
the, I don't know any,
I don't know any UFC fighters,
but even just what wrestlers go through,
I'm just like, man, that's
unbelievably hard for your body too,
because what they're doing, car accident
all over and over and over again,
over and over and over again.
I felt like that
actually in Orlando. Well, you
know, there's a lot of 'em for sure.
There's a lot of bad feelings that come
from bombing and it's not good for you
and it's, it's damaging. The
issue about sports though,
or wrestling or anything along those
lines is that it sort of breaks your body
down and then you got to live the last
third of your life or half of your life
with a body that's essentially wrecked
from the first half isn't the same as
ballerinas. Some of them, you know, I
don't know if all of them get fucked up.
They all get fucked up. I don't know.
Like what is the thing that goes wrong?
What goes wrong? Oh, like
you're just murdering your body.
Like just the arthritis that sets in
and standing on your toes. If you don't,
if you don't actually ever get injured,
which they all do,
it's still just so hard on your body.
Like you can't like walk as long
as he would. You know what I heard?
I heard they just fuck a lot and
they blame the injuries on ballet.
Endless Ballerina.
I heard they just get a lot of ballet
Dick like Baryshnikov Dick talk like
crazy. The guy from that movie
blocks all of those girls.
The Guy, the director guy, he's always the
guy. He makes it, he's aloof with them.
He plays games.
He fucked the other girls to remember.
I remember he was like really mean
and he got them really insecure.
He pulls him in clothes.
Then he pushes him away.
He plays those creepy creepy games.
Yeah, I guess you're right. That guy did.
Fuck everybody.
If he's a heterosexual,
he's around all these insecure
women and he has a power over them.
Like he gets it. He's the director.
That dude just bang and left and right.
That dirty bastard. He's
horrible. He's a terrible person.
Might as well be drugging them.
My opinion,
it seems like what guys should do guys
become comics to, to hook up with girls.
It's stupid just,
well the one guy in ballet,
well I don't know if guys become
comics to hook up with girls,
but they definitely become funny to make
girls laugh at them and then along the
way they look at their career options and
usually their burger fork and form and
standup looks incredibly attractive.
And then along the way they realize from
doing shows that you could hook up with
girls. Yeah. I think very few
comics get into comedy going,
I'm going to be really funny
so I can hook up with girls.
I think it's sort of a
consequence of like, you know,
they just realized as they were
after they started. Oh yeah,
I'm friends with her. Yeah, I guess they,
they just make it sound like that was
a part of why they got into it. Well,
I think it's probably part of what
makes him funny for sure. Yeah.
It was probably one of the only times I
was ever funny before I was a comedian
was like talking to girls, you know, we're
trying, you're trying to impress him.
It's probably one of the only times I
was ever funny like making fun of things
are mocking things and it was that
or locker room stuff with my friends.
There's a lot of that. A lot of like,
oh, just like me. Well I, you know,
I came from a weird place
because I came from a PR, like a,
I was a martial arts instructor.
I know it was a competitor and I did.
That was like the main
focus in my life growing up,
so I didn't have a normal
upbringing in that sense.
It was very abnormal.
There was no partying,
there was no very little drinking
or any of that. You know,
had a couple of girlfriends that tolerated
me for small periods of time and then
they'd eventually just get
tired of me being crazy girls.
Just like going to your like
martial arts shows like, yeah.
I don't think I ever brought one to a
fight and actual fight. Too much pressure.
Yeah. I wouldn't want to watch him sit
there in the audience watching me and me
thinking about them watching me.
Like my sister came to see me fight
once and I remember it to be in a wreck.
It's one thing I really appreciated
about my parents. They never,
they never like for, they never said, I am
going to your fight. Like you know they,
they would say, do you want us to go
this fuck that. I'm like, no, don't go.
Oh really? No. I don't want,
I don't want them to see
me hurting anybody and be
upset at me and I didn't want
to see anybody hurting me and them being
upset and then the idea that I could
get hurt in front of my mother,
it was like extra pressure.
The idea that I would lose in front of
my mother. That was also extra pressure.
Like it's a very solitary
pursuit. Martial arts. Yes.
They've seen me do stand up a bunch
of times. It could be a complete, no,
not at all. Totally different thing, you
know, because the stand up, it's just fun.
You know? It's, it was bad
at the beginning when I
wasn't very good, you know,
I'd be like, fuck man, I'm bombing. So my
parents, but uh, once I got good it was,
um, it was pretty easy to have him
there. It's fun. It's fun to have them.
They're fighting was a totally
different thing though. It's just more,
more creepy. It's just too many
things to manage, you know,
you're more inside your head.
So I wasn't really fun.
I was rarely funny with girls even,
let's just rarely funny. Yeah.
I wasn't funny at all until I decided to
become a comedian. I was more of like a,
a questioning person than funny.
But you seem like,
I think it would be
funny just by accident.
Like didn't you just make people laugh?
Well,
that's what happened was the reason I
got talked into doing stand up in the
first place was guys in the locker room.
I would be doing impressions of, uh,
each other.
Like I'd be doing impressions
of my instructor having
sex with one of students,
uh, or other friends. You know,
I would make fun of things,
but it was really rare, you know?
But every now and then I would do,
it wasn't like something I did every day,
but when you did it, everybody was like,
every now and then I would, I would
wait until they were good. You know,
I'd have something,
I had to have some something
actually funny. Yeah. I wasn't
like, it was a very quiet thing.
Like Marshall,
everybody was very friendly and
everybody would go into the locker room.
What's up, what's up with it? But
we knew what we're going to do.
We're going to go out there and we're
going to kick each other and punch each
other.
It was a very nerve wracking thing to
be like very close with people that beat
you up.
But like
I know that that fighting
is totally different.
But I do see a lot of parallels with,
with stand up with that because it's like,
yeah, these are the people you're most
threatened by. You feel the closest too.
In a way. Yeah. Yeah. These are, there's,
there's some similarities for sure.
I think there's some,
yeah.
Thinking about just, and even
like, I like watching, um, uh,
I always liked rap battles.
I mean, growing up I just
like was interested in them.
I still like them and then,
and I never made the connection
that those were kind of like,
roasts are like hanging out with
comics to me, but it's like, of course,
like even the Wu Tang album
[inaudible] um, at the beginning of a,
of method man of, uh, that song. It's like
they're just trashing each other saying,
right, what they're going to do. And
I'm like, and I loved, I loved that,
that growing up.
And then I'm like,
I never even made that connection
until really recently. Oh yeah.
Well, battle rap is all about, you know,
coming out on top and everybody would
come up with the most vicious scathing
shit. And I'd say about a dude's
mother. Yeah. And make it rhyme.
But how many times you've seen
battle rap that ends in fisticuffs?
There's a bunch of those videos online.
Right.
It always looks like they're about
to some fair are, you know, they're,
they're saying some really nasty shit to
each other. Yeah. Yeah. In a way. Yeah.
I think that's probably a lot
like stand up, but stand up.
It's rare that we go head to head with
each other like that. Like that's doesn't,
it's only a roast where that
kind of happens and even then,
but then can't respond for awhile.
Yeah. But even if it's not like,
but even I know you, you and I,
both of heckler people put videos of us
when dealing with hecklers online and
that feels like you're fighting training.
Like I think that stuff
plays a part in just in,
just like your defense mechanisms,
how you're set up,
how you've been preparing
for these moments you didn't
even know you're going to
have
sort of,
it's also you recognize you have to
handle something in real time and you have
to also be completely in the moment
while you're handling it. Yeah.
Because if you, you're, you're
directing a moment. Yeah.
Work x amount of people in the audience.
They all paid to see you and some shit's
going down in real time if they need to
control.
And sometimes you'll slip and you'll
say something awkward or you just say
something that's just like
forced or stupid or too
much. And the crowd was like,
Whoa, Amy, he's just a drunk.
I mean I've had some people swear that
things were planted just cause people are
so ridiculous. Right? I had a guy, God
damn, and I can't remember where I feel,
I want to say it was Milwaukee,
but there was a guy that was so drunk
that he came up to the side of the stage
and he was literally falling
over and he reached up his hand,
like to shake my hand and then like was
like blacking out. And I caught his hand.
I was holding onto his wrist.
I was literally keeping this guy standing
like he was that fucked up. Right.
And the audience was how little I'm like,
this is,
I've never had to hold a guy up.
Like how fucked up is this guy?
Like he stumbled out of his chair, came
like lunging towards the, uh, the, the,
the stage to the point where I was
wondering if he was handicapped.
I was wondering if you had like an
issue with his muscles or something,
some physical issue.
And that's really hard.
That's what it's the hardest to deal
with somebody. Like if you're like, wait,
this guy might have had something wrong
with them. Like top of being fucked up.
Yeah. But the fucked up thing,
there's a video of it somewhere.
I have a video of me
holding this guy up by,
so it was like to show that it really
is real. Love it. They're like,
cause it's like this real moment.
They're like, well, so ridiculous.
But I mean those moments like
Amy Schumer's responsible for,
you're responsible for, you know, in
real time it, here's the guy. Like he's,
he's standing there.
Are you going back to your seat? If You
pee your pants, we're going to nuts. Yeah.
Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead. Amy Schumer
is going to pee while this guy,
but I want to sit
back.
Man represents the world.
He's the roots of your tree.
Well you are right now.
Maybe the trunk is guys ever survived.
We're going to learn something
just by watching you take,
you need to sit the fuck down across
legging and just close your eyes and think
about the seventh grade cause there's
no way making up those stairs.
Clearly you've made some mistakes.
Let's go back.
Let's go back to grammar school.
Let's go to seventh grade
feeling good.
Two years you get to be 14 that's
when your brother got some sex.
Are you really trying to walk?
Why are you doing that?
Get on your knees and your hands and crawl
because you don't have the
mentality of a Zubin right now.
That's why your mind doesn't
want to do that like a baby.
You'd be fine.
That's that guy.
This was his buddy who's with him.
Are you with you?
Is that your friend whose weight?
Then you folks have sensible,
fairly sober. This is men.
Traveling Solo was amazing.
Nope,
I don't drink that much to stay alive.
Do you have any idea that I was
grabbing him and holding on questions
and then there's that happening over there
and he's going to look up
when you love.
Do you see that guys as he
slowly makes it to that toilet.
Okay. There's those moments, man,
we need to put your forehead
on the white porcelain.
You pee and you're like,
I gotta fix so many things about my life
staring into the abyss of that white
porcelain just comes back to the answers.
I think that's probably the end of it.
Somebody is fucked up though.
Is He?
Okay. That's probably what
he was thinking about.
Why he's doing it too much pressure.
Just always looking for data.
I completely forgot about that dude.
I totally forgot about that whole
exchange about how long it went on,
but the guy was so drunk
that I was holding him up
and he didn't even look up at
me.
He was so drunk.
He was just like letting me hold him up
and he was just sort of looking around
at the crowd trying to figure out why
when you were like, where's the
security of this venue? Like, who's Sir?
Oh, no, no, no. They handled
it right away. Like you
could see right here, while,
while this guy is a stumbling,
this guy comes over,
the security comes over and
grabs him and they cart them off.
And then I started talking about that.
Guys like the roots of your tree.
He represents life. Let him hold you up.
And the guy walked the, the dude towards,
uh, towards the back of the
room and then they might,
you talked him through it like,
yeah. Well I had to, I mean, you,
I had to talk about it.
It was just so ridiculous.
I'd never seen a guy that
drunk. He was, I mean, he was,
and there was no way he was talking.
He could barely move his body. Right.
He was just making noises with his mouth.
It didn't represent words.
You could see that he was
trying to speak English,
but he was so drunk he couldn't talk
at all. Yeah. This guy's a victim.
Start wondering. You start wondering
what happened, how'd it go wrong?
Right. That's what I was to me too.
And then sometimes like, you know,
if people like keep keep firing at
me, I'm like, don't cause I will,
I will pinpoint what happened.
It's not good for either one of us.
Know the crowds. Like even if you win,
you're gonna feel bad later. It's
going to be like, oh did I go too far?
You learned that lesson,
you know, you learn that
lesson. Then you're like,
I know if I say one more thing I will
regret it for the rest of my life. So,
well then sometimes it's funny when
you go too far and you go, all right,
I went too far. Yeah,
sorry everybody. Yeah,
it's all like, do you, if you actually get
angry, that's the debt. That's the thing.
If you actually get angry,
but I yeah,
cause nobody wants to see that.
But I learned from when I was opening
for Norton and the tell on the road,
because people would yell shit
at them and they wouldn't,
they wouldn't fire back. It was
never like they were being attacked.
They would just diffuse.
So I try to do that now.
But then if somebody keeps coming,
but then I've also seen if somebody keeps
coming at them, they will go to town.
Yeah.
There's a difference between someone
having fun and someone that's like fucking
it all up. You know, at the
risk of encouraging this,
cause I'm not encouraging this,
but when I was in New York,
discouraged when I was in New York,
this guy yelled out something that was
fucking hilarious. It was uh, I was uh,
I was talking about the most,
it was trying to figure out who the most
famous woman in the world was setting
up this bit and the guy goes,
your mom
just for childish.
I'm 12 reasons I started laughing.
It was just the perfect timing.
Cause it's like, first of all,
that is not true. Your mom is not the
most famous woman, but it doesn't matter
who makes a big best cheeseburgers.
Maybe your mom got me,
who suck the most.
Dick, probably your mom.
Like somewhere along the line,
throughout history there's gotta be a
woman who is sucked the most Dick's ever.
There's a world record holder.
They probably don't keep it officially.
It's not a video. It's
probably done. I'll probably,
it's on a cave somewhere
carved into the rocks.
It was probably an old record
that nobody ever even clean,
close to touching with little dick.
Chalk marks
your kettle bells and be like,
wow,
what was going on with this society when
a prisoner is calculating how many days?
So they get out till they get released.
They makes those fives on the wall for
straight ones and the one across you go
over to her,
her a door of death.
And it's just all these dex endless dex
in the cave and write by the cave door.
Brighton. How many dicks you
sucks so hard to get. You know,
if you have a limps tough
to get some buffalo,
you've got to do what you gotta do.
Oh, but I'm at my point is, yeah,
just that's your mom. I mean, I've
never had somebody heckle that. Good.
Yeah, that's, that's a good hackle. But
it was only in the moment. It was good.
It was another moment.
It could be
bad, you know, at all.
Anything out it shows. Yeah.
Don't it worked that time.
Then let's talk, I love talking to the
crowd, but did you ever do a Q and a?
You know what you should do?
There's a thing
they're doing in an la, it's a
podcast called Thunderpussy. Yeah.
And Thunderpussy is you don't go
on stage with any material at all.
Zero material and the audience
yells out suggestions. No,
it's red band, red band.
And um, Jeremiah, Jeremiah,
Jeremiah walked in, sorry, Jeremiah, I
spaced on his name. Jeremiah Watkins,
very funny young kid.
And he and Brian have this podcast where
they have guys go up there and they do
that. They do everything
is completely off the cuff.
You do everything with the audience,
but isn't it better to do
the stuff that you know work
sometimes,
but as an artistic exercise,
it's a great exercise in because you
come up with bits and then they become
actual beds.
You come up with bits when someone yells
out something and you have a suggestion
and then you try to work
it out like several times.
Several Times I've come up with actual
real bits from that that have become real
bits.
I try to like make myself do at least a
couple of new things and every night on
stage. That's good. Yeah.
But I mean it's, it's hard.
It's definitely hard. Like they
can sense it. They're like,
that's one of the things that's amazing
about this I this Thunderpussy ideas
because you're doing an hour and
yeah, well me, I did an hour,
I did an hour, one hour once
in an hour, 10 another time.
How much time did you get out of that
in the long run for or 10 minutes of the
two sets. Yeah. That's amazing. Two
sets is 10 whole minutes. So you know,
a lot of it gets tossed out.
A lot of it's in the moment.
A lot of it is not applicable
or maybe it is someday.
Once I hashed it out and was
here in Scotland, Edinburgh,
people that do that,
they say like, you know,
you're there for like a month and you
have to do a different hour every night.
That's what some comics say
that they go and they do that.
You get so much time out of, it didn't
merit or is it Melbourne? One of those.
The Marin has a fantastic story about
going over to some festival in bombing
horrifically. That's probably
Melbourne. I think it's a male.
It was a great story though.
That's a really good at telling it cause
he's like really early on in his career
and just the whole thing was just wrong.
You know the wrong vibe thing where it's,
you get caught up in the wrong and
if you start off a week following,
totally brings up so
many feelings right away.
Never recover that feeling when you
start off Thursday night eating shit on
stage in your head,
you're like,
how am I even still standing here
when all the bloods and my head,
you can't even believe they're
gonna let you go up on Friday.
But it's just because they couldn't find
a substitute for you and you're like,
oh my God,
here we go again.
Seeing spots like it's such a bad feeling.
I had two sets of this one
place in Connecticut. The
first that I had was great.
It was really fun. It was easy.
It was fun. The second set I had,
it was awful. I was
terrible. I just bombed. No,
it wasn't even hard for it.
It was like some Bar Gig in Connecticut,
but it was just early on in
my career and it was just,
I had another one after
that that went well,
but the everyone gave me the stink.
I stink.
I couldn't believe that I did well
this time compared to the last time.
They want to keep bringing up the last
time, even though I had a good set,
they kept wanting to bring up the last
time when I ate shit up there. I'm like,
I know I didn't do it on purpose,
feeling it.
I bombed so bad. I don't think
I ever told us here. But um,
at the Schomburg Improv,
which they call the Chicago Improv,
I know where that place,
it's an hour away from Chicago already.
Miles from Chicago was an hour
if you're lucky. But anyway,
I went there and I was opening for
Tammy and I went out there and I'm like,
I did.
And I was used to,
I was like in the middle doing last comic.
So I've been dealing with all paid
audiences. So I was like, I was like,
I think I'm a killer now.
And I went up,
I mean bomb it like 20
minutes of just zero,
like where I was, like I almost said,
is this thing on? Like it was that bad.
And so it's my,
it was my second night and I'm just,
I'm like 10 minutes into my 20 and I'm
dying and Tammy comes on stage and takes
the mic out of my hand and
I'm like, Whoa, you know,
and I'm always like ready to say
something. Like I'm a wise that I had,
I couldn't believe it. She goes,
Amy, um, and she's like, everyone,
I'm really sorry but there's
been a bomb threat. And I'm like,
this is what she says when
someone's bombing like this bitch,
I cannot believe this. But
there was, it's in a strip mall,
there was a bomb threat in the mall,
so we all to evacuate and she
wanted to be the ones to tell them.
And so we're all like, ah. And I was
like, fucking thank God, you know,
this divider or all filing out together
and I'm filing out with the crowd.
And they're all talking about
like how horrible I was.
And then just night after night,
just taking it to the chin,
just going out there and just eating it.
So awful bomb threat while
you're bombing is never,
never good though.
I don't know if I have an APP on my phone,
like calling a friend, like just
buffalo in five minutes. Okay.
What was wrong?
It was me.
I wasn't comic.
Just I think bombing so many times that
you just don't care and then once you
don't care. Yeah, because they're
not worried. They trust you.
And cause I think my jokes were funny.
It wasn't that my material,
I got that much better. You're just
nervous up there. I was just like,
is this okay? Is this okay? Is this funny?
Oh that wasn't funny. Okay. Like quick,
let me get to this other
thing. Is this fun? You know,
just tap dancing through my set.
And then, and then it was like, oh,
that made you upset.
Well let me say this thing that's 10
times worse than that last thing you got
mad at and I don't care. And then, yeah,
just and then just being
totally unapologetic. Yeah.
Now it's more difficult as
a woman to do stand up. No,
I've had a very sweet path like I,
and I think I've worked really hard
and I think, I dunno what the quote is,
but like opportunity plus
preparation equals something.
Okay. Thanks. Um, I don't know, but
it's like I have worked really hard but,
but I, um, I think it's annoying.
I think it's harder to be a woman.
I think being a chick sucks and I wouldn't
wish it on anybody really. For Real.
Yes. Really? Yes. It's awful. It's awful.
But everything,
you're like born with this invisible
calendar counting down to your last
fuckable day. You're, you're,
you're valued by your
appearance above all else,
but at the same
you bake less. You're, you're
taught that there's no,
there's no ceiling to what you can
do. No limit. And then you learn. Yes,
there is and society wants only a specific
thing from you and even though your
program to different ones,
right.
But aren't you lucky breaks that that's
always going to be the case. Right.
But aren't you proof positive that
there is no ceiling and that you've,
you can be successful with hard work and
talent. I mean that's what you've done,
right. I think you're way more
talented than a lot of men.
I know way more successful as well,
but the people that have seen those men
and me perform would still tell me that
I was their favorite female
comedian they've ever seen.
Ah.
Like it's a handicap like you would say.
Would you say that like you're my favorite
black comedian I've ever seen. It's,
I think it's really weird.
Yeah. Well fuck them for that.
But I've said that before. She's one of
the funniest girls ever. All time. Yeah.
Well, you know like Roseanne Barr
was on and um, I went like super,
super conscious to not say that she's
one of the funniest women of all time.
Cause I think she's one of the great ones.
Yeah. I think if you had to pick like,
you know, like a top 50 greatest comedian
list ever. Roseanne Barr in my opinion,
is like, she's a real, she
was a real pioneer. Yeah.
Because she had a very specific
unique style. When she came out,
she was hard hitting and aggressive and
she didn't give a fuck if you liked her.
She wasn't trying to look pretty
shad. Ah, you know, she just,
and she shoved it down your throat just
knowing it was good and well written
stuff and performance
delivery. So yeah, I, I made,
I could see how that would be annoying.
Like just numbers.
Like how many,
how many female comics are headlining
theaters on the road. Right.
How many of them are in
successful relationships?
How many of them?
Yeah,
you've seen a Palicki. That's it. Yeah.
They sort of broke the rule. The boss.
I mean I'm Voss and Bonnie. Yeah.
You know, there's like, there's
a couple of exceptions, you know,
statistically it's not
looking good for the Laneys.
Awesome. Bonnie's hilarious too. Cause
Bonnie's a smart one and bosses the,
you know, the, the, the, the guy who
was constantly the button box there,
he's the butt of the jokes, like
all of their podcasts, you know,
it's like Shim her shitting
all over how dummy.
Yeah. But then it's like,
you know, it's like I,
I am successful as a comic right now.
But then it's like,
but then there's also a price to
be paid for that, for being a girl
anyway. Okay. But is it with everybody
or is it with idiots, you know,
and isn't the price that you pay when
you're rowing idiots? No, I mean,
good people, nice people. I think.
I think it's, most people
still want a kind of, I think,
I think some people are grateful
for for the female comics that they,
they love love. Like, like
I was grateful for the,
my favorite comics where
we're girls growing up and,
and those comedic actresses and
I was really grateful for them.
And so I still,
and I hope that people will feel
that way about me one day, but,
um,
what the fuck am I talking about?
I'm just talking about the differences
when we were just discussing the
differences between men and female comics
and how few female comics there are
and about,
when you look at the number of females
that are headlining theaters and that
they were always your biggest influences.
And you're always big fans of these female
comedians. That's what you're saying.
Good listener. I'm very
fascinated by the subject because,
um,
you know,
I had a conversation once with Judy gold
about an interview that I did where we
were, we were talking about,
she's so funny. She's very
funny. She's an animal too.
She, she fucking, she's a killer.
She's so good. Uh, but she's also,
you know, smart quick. If you fuck
with her, she'll kill you. You know,
she knows how to just shut things down
like especially a heckler shuts them down.
Oh, I remember it. I was gonna say,
um, well please do it. Say it then.
Oh,
sorry.
But I think a lot of people are probably
pretty relieved when Judy and I leave
the room.
Wow. That's, come on. No
one who's worth a fuck.
Yeah. I, no, I think you're right.
And the people I'm close to and the people
that I love and that I care about are,
you know, are in our, into it.
But I think still there's a lot of work
to be done in the world with like the
perception of what we want from,
from women
maybe. Um, I, I see what
you're saying. Um, I, I, I'm,
I'm sure I would see it from a
completely different perspective.
If I was you and I lived your experiences.
My experience though with friends and
people that I care about is, you know,
I don't always agree with Jerry Seinfeld,
but one thing that Jerry Seinfeld
said that I really do agree with,
there's someone was talking
about diversity and comedy
and he was like, look, I,
this is all I speak. It's funny, I
just, I want to know what's funny.
Like what I think is our people are
funny if they're men, if they're women,
if they're black, if they're
white, he goes, I just like funny.
And that's true because Chris rock
is one of his best friends. Um,
w w was the dude who used to host,
um, MTV half hour comedy hour.
Mario Joiner is a guy who's been
a good friend forever. Yeah. Yeah.
But I think he's,
I think that the conversation was with
Collin Quinn when he was talking about
why he had no women or,
or black people on the first season of
his writing and in cars with comedians
and, and it's like funny as funny,
but are you looking for, what's fun?
Are you, I don't think
of, um, you know, it.
Do you have your hand on the
pulse of who's it, who's stand up?
Are you going down to
watch Jerry Seinfeld?
I'm saying that in
general. Like, you know,
you know what's fun and
I think that's true.
What's funny is funny and like I don't,
I don't,
I would never specify like this
is my favorite female comic.
It was my favorite black comic.
Like that's insane to me. Um,
but I think people what they are
looking for, if they're like,
I'm going to Google, um, comedians,
uh, they're good there. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Is that what it's called?
Yes. That's what it is. It's a talk
show, but I don't think so. He does it.
He interviews people like Larry David,
Eddie Izzard.
Was it him and talking on Stern
about college? Well, it's, he,
he interviews people that he thinks
are interesting. That's all it is.
I mean he just gets like David Letterman
goes for a drive and his Volvo. Yeah.
And then the second season he had
Sarah on, he had, he had, you know,
he had women on, cause Colin was like,
you're gonna get a lot of shit for this.
But that's not why he did it. Yeah. No,
I think that's what he's saying when
he said the interview, he's like,
I don't care. Yeah. He goes, all I care
about. It's funny. I think you're right.
That I think I'm like that. You don't
think he's like that? No, I don't know.
I have no idea. I have no idea.
But what I'm saying is, um,
I think that that's what he
was talking about was Collin.
I'm telling him like you need,
you can't just,
no,
it was actually an interview.
It was an interview where you asking him
in an interview and Sterns, here it is.
This guy here,
I'll play it.
Mostly the, the guests are mostly white
males of 22 episodes that get into that.
No.
Look over here. Peter,
what are you saying?
What's going on here?
Oh, this really pisses me off,
but God had really pisses me off.
That's okay.
I'm go ahead.
But you made a comment on the Tina Fey
episode that I thought was interesting
that I'd like to get your
thoughts on a little bit more.
You said you were talking
to her that the end,
you said something about
the female comedians.
It's a struggle for them to balance
their feminine projections with their
comedic gold and its context of comedy,
not gender diverse.
I just want to know what
you meant by that. Well,
I'm was kind of curious what it's like
to be a woman in comedy as opposed to a
man. There was a little bit of a
difference and I thought that might be an
interesting thing to discuss from her
perspective. She saw successful at it,
and I'm just wondering
how she looked at it,
if she even thought about it and she kind
of gave me the answer, which is, yeah,
you do have to think about that,
but you know,
it's just another thing to
think about. Okay. All right.
Yeah. Hold on. A lot
of things about the communities of cars
in the beginning and the first 10 I did,
I think we're all white males and
people writing all about that, which I,
part of the reason why people had tweeted
at me when I said I'm interviewing
with Jerry Seinfeld is okay, ask him about
their agenda. Their diversity on there.
Yeah. I mean it's, people think it's,
it's the census or something. I mean,
we represent the, the actual
pie chart of, of, of America.
Who Cares? It's just funny,
you know? Funny is the, is the,
is the world that I live in. You're
funny. I'm interested. You're not funny.
I'm not interested and I have no interest
in gender or race or anything like
that, but everyone else gets kind
of with their little calculating,
is this the exact right mix? You know? Uh,
I think that's a,
to me it's anti comedy.
It's the anti comedy. It's,
it's more about, you know,
PC nonsense. Okay. Then are you
making us laugh or not? Right, right.
He definitely also talked about that.
What he just sat on stern and,
but in reference Collins saying
that he was going to get,
get a bunch a bunch of shit about that.
Oh, so he's talked about it a few times.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, but I think, um, uh,
I don't know. I mean you
disagree with them? No,
I think I'm not going to disagree with
the statement. What's funny is funny. I,
I think what somebody thinks is fine.
I don't think you should just have a,
a woman or a,
um,
a person who's not white on to
not make people upset. Right.
I don't think that's, um, you
know, I have my own feelings about,
um, like I have my stuff,
my old stuff would,
that triggers for me is going
back to when I was young,
like really young in school and,
and,
and being funny and having,
but,
but knowing and getting a reaction from
people like just try to be like nice and
pretty like, that's what we want from
you. Like be a girl. Like shut up.
The boys are talking, we're
funny. And knowing I was funnier.
Wait a minute.
Why does that him saying that he doesn't
believe in anything but funny trigger
that in you?
Because I don't believe that
that he's aware are looking.
I think,
I think that um,
I think that maybe he would be more likely
to dismiss someone or not really pay
that much attention to um,
to something other than what he's
used to thinking is, is funny.
Like it like it being like a white,
if your favorite comedians that people
you want to have on the first season of
your show,
your first 10 episodes are all one
type then then that's your type.
And I don't think that you can say
what I don't think you can say.
What's funny is funny because
there are plenty of comedians.
I go up there and kill and
I'm like nothing, you know,
and like Chris Rock, I think I said this
on here last time, but he told me like,
I was like, how was, how was his sat? And
he'll be like, he killed. I'm like, yeah,
but how was it? And he's
like, no, respect the kill.
And like I was just talking about this
with Wanda Sykes. She was like, yes,
sometimes you can't. And I'm like,
yeah, sometimes you can't. So it's like,
okay, what's funny is funny. What? What
makes what makes a room full of people,
you know? Tears laughing. You can say,
well that's, they're laughing. It's funny.
But to you it's not. It's not funny,
but it's not up to you. But I'm,
I can't tell you what's funny and what's
not like I don't think anyone can say
funny is funny actually
because it's subjective.
It's subjective. Right?
But you say what's funny to
you and that is what's funny.
I mean when you're saying to him is
his who he chose to having a show.
I totally understand that,
but I don't understand why you connected
to your personal feelings on people
saying that we weren't saying that you
weren't funny and you were a girl and
that you were actually fun. It
wasn't fun. They were saying, well,
they wanted you to be quiet.
They wanted you to be quiet and they
wanted the guys to be talking and you were
funnier than the God. As a person with
a personality was like dismissed. Like,
you're right, we will come get
the girls like when we need them.
I understand you from you
personally, but him. Why does that,
his statement had zero to do with gender
or race wasn't a gender or race because
he was saying very clearly he doesn't
care. As long as you're funny,
that's what he shares. You can make
a statement. What's funny is funny.
I mean like that's so
easy to say like you just,
that's such a like, I don't care. You
can just say, I don't care what's,
what's funny is funny. So you're
accusing him of being dishonest. No,
I think that that is absolutely what
he means is I'm so confused. I don't,
I love you. I don't want to get into
an argument with you about that.
We're in an argument. Okay, good. I
want, I want you to understand too,
what I'm saying is I believe
that he believes what he's
saying and I hear saying
he discriminates in some way because of
his choices and that his choices should
reflect a broader range
of human beings just to,
I don't think I would never use like
the word should with what Jerry Seinfeld
should be watching. So tell me
how his choices bring up in you,
this idea that you personally
discriminated against.
Because I think to say what's
funny is funny is like,
I don't think that's true.
Um,
because because comedy is so subjective,
like somebody gets to him. Right?
But wait, let me, let me
work through this. Um, but,
but that's the thing. What's
funny is funny to me. It's like,
um, so, but, but he didn't,
I don't think he said that.
I think he said what's funny is funny,
not what appeals interested.
He said the language I speak is funny.
All I'm interested in is if you're funny.
That's what he said.
Right? So saying that,
but then also choosing
10 white male comics, um,
for the first season of his
show. He's saying like, sorry,
if you guys were funnier,
um,
other races and weight and women,
then you would have been on the first
season of my show. And I'm saying,
I don't think that he's seen,
I don't think that he's as open
to seeing people other than that,
that prototype.
And that is what connects me
to my childhood stuff because
people are used to,
this is who I'm used to being
funny people who look like this,
people who do this. And, and so
that's, that's why I'm connecting it.
I understand. I understand
what you're saying. Um,
I think you're adding a lot of extra
stuff to what he's saying and I think
you're also not taking into consideration
the idea that this is his individual
creation,
this idea of a web show and that he has
probably dozens and dozens of friends.
If he's doing 10 episodes and he has
dozens of the greatest comedians in the
world, I don't think that it should
be up to him to diversify his,
his cast. So then what he said is
essentially, I'm interested in,
are people funny? If you're funny,
that's what I'm interested in. To him.
That's a true statement.
It may be very well suggest subjective.
You might think that some of those
people are not funny, whereas you know,
there's people that think that a
perfect example is Gilbert Godfried.
This people that think
that Gilbert Godfrey's the
funniest dude to ever walk for
case.
Not every comedian I know.
No, no, no. What I'm saying is every
comedian, okay, you can say, well,
this guy's hilarious. And then someone
else will say, and I don't like it. When,
when I would never say any comedians.
Not Funny. Like you could just know, oh,
he's not funny. It's like, no, you
don't think he's funny. Exactly.
It's like everything else.
Music, it's like movies.
It's like anything else I don't want,
I don't think Seinfeld should have done
anything different and I don't, um,
I don't, I don't think that he should have
to, I think he wants to make the show.
He should make it with the
people you want. Just like the,
like girls that show got a bunch of
shit for just having white people on,
like let them make the show that
they want. Right. But I'm allowed to,
that's allowed to trigger something in
me that I can feel like his choice to not
do that.
Even though he's every right.
And I think you should make
the show you want to make.
That does trigger something
in me. I don't, it's not that.
Do you feel it's fair?
Does it make sense,
objective when you analyze your
feelings inside of you? No. No,
you don't validate them.
You don't try to justify them there.
I understand that I have a
right to my feelings about it.
I don't think they're right or wrong.
Okay.
And I think all day long we're
triggered by, by people or interactions.
It's like why you yell at a a
bank teller? It's like, wait,
why did I tell her I don't go to a bank,
I have a businessman,
but do you know what I
mean? It's like, you know,
somebody triggers something in
you and it brings up old stuff.
And I think Seinfeld so funny.
I really like him.
I see him on him at the
cellar and I, but, but um,
seeing that hearing I'm talking
about Alan Stern, it, it brings up,
it does bring that up for me and I don't,
I don't think that a,
and I understand why it doesn't
make sense to you. Well know.
I'm not saying that doesn't make sense.
Your feelings absolutely makes sense.
You know, we might disagree
with whether or not it's valid,
but you seem to think
that it's not even valid.
That it's just reality and just these are
feelings that are brought up and these
are your feelings and you don't,
you don't justify them or rationalize
them in any way. Just being honest.
I think it makes perfect sense for
why that would trigger that in me.
Right. But as long as you don't
hold them responsible for that,
I don't think he should do anything
different. Some people do though.
There's a lot of, well that's good.
You have a very healthy attitude.
I mean, I really don't, I think,
but I think what's saying like
what's funny is funny is it,
I think that statement should, and maybe
you did it and I just didn't catch it,
but it should include what, what's
funny to me. It's funny to me because
it was funny. It's funny, he does implied,
you know, he's saying my interest is,
I'm interested in what's funny.
Speak with like a lot of
authority about a lot of,
um, things. I and I, I don't know, I've
never heard him say this, but I think,
I think some people can act like they are
the decider of what's funny and what's
not. And I don't think, and
I've, you know, I've had a great,
I've had a great reaction.
Like I feel very lucky and like work has
paid off and people come to see me and
I make people laugh I think.
But um, if someone's like,
I don't like your standup, I'm like,
sure. If they're like, you're not funny.
I'm like, no, that's not true.
Right. Okay. I get all that personal shit.
But I think you might be applying it
in this situation in a way that's like,
you're adding a bunch of stuff
to what he said. You know,
I really think you have to take
it. He said, well this, this,
the feelings like this connecting
it to him saying that, you know,
or him being some sort of
an arbitrary of what's,
you know what I should add into
the mix here? Your pms in no,
no, but again, that is
something that nature creates.
It's not my fault that
we're punished for like,
why are you being crazy? Like, do you
think I want to feel crazy? Am I like,
Ooh, can I please link, bleed
once a month and feel insane?
Cause that's what I want. No.
And I think I might be pms.
No, but I also, you know,
I've been past it that I've been working
at the comedy cellar for seven years
now and been a standard for 10.
And I also, um, you know, I,
I've interactions with,
with Seinfeld once in a while.
And so this isn't just
me seeing the comedian,
Jerry Seinfeld has a television,
has a,
a web series and you didn't use it.
I'm not just reading these headlines.
I also have like, you know, um,
personal experiences with him that leads
you to believe you thinks in a certain
way.
No. Just like, and you
know what these are,
I'm sure they're unfounded.
What they charge, what they
trigger and in me, but you,
you can't help that stuff. People
do it to me all day. I know.
I look like I look like somebody
you went to high school with that,
that like was annoying or
a bitch or something. And
then, and people just don't,
Eh, and you're like, that's not, it's
not my fault, but you're not wrong.
You know, so, so yeah. So when I see
that video and what's funny is funny,
I do feel like, kind of
like he's dismissing, um,
not by the,
not by the choice to,
to just use white male comics in
the first season of your show. Like,
do your thing, do whatever
you want. Of course. But, um,
but it, you know, it does, it
does bring up feelings in me,
which that's okay.
Yeah. I mean, as long as you're
not blaming him and you are,
you just doing it as being
honest about your feelings.
And sometimes people trigger
feelings in people unintentionally.
I'm not blaming him for anything. Things
are going well. Like I of course not.
I'm saying that it doesn't mean
that those feelings are invalid.
If something triggers those feelings,
it doesn't mean that this look life
triggers shit in people. You know,
you watch an eagle snatch a fon
and, and fly off with it. Oh,
you might freak out. But guess what? It's
tough shit. People don't, people will
collage out of me like a girl.
When I was opening for a towel,
she would write to me like,
I know you're having sex them.
It was like,
ah,
he's my friend and I opened her as
the girl that Intel was a dating.
I don't think so. Just
tell fan. And it was like,
I know like she had created this
whole thing and I people reach out.
That was made by the way under
tell fucking,
but when people like are mad about
something like that, you know, I,
I would like right, like, or I would just
think like, I hope she's okay. You know,
like, this isn't for, you know,
I'd hope to get hit in the head by
a fucking media how many people,
but I'm just like,
you know,
people like will feel real strong about
things that make no sense or they have
sort of no business. Um, like it does it.
Yeah. Just like, doesn't make any sense,
but it's like, so you feel that
way and that's okay. I think.
I think he's obviously,
he's an amazing comic and made it one
of my favorite television shows ever.
And um, and it, it does
it and it's allowed to,
it's allowed to trigger
something in me that he thought,
I mean, you're, you're also trying to
dance around your words and be, you know,
very fair about all this.
It's a very tricky subject.
It's a bold one to sort of take on.
I worked with these people. Yeah. No,
I know what you're saying. I
know what you're saying. I'm,
and I'm glad you don't think that.
I think in that way at all. I tried.
I think it triggers something in you
that cause you're mad that people were
never had a hard time. Yeah.
So what, what, what was that?
Because I don't think that you should
be forced to hang around with anybody
other than the people that you
choose to hang around with,
whether it's cast them on
your own television show
or whether it's put them on
your podcast or whether it's go
with on the road with them. Yeah,
it's stupid.
I don't think you should have to,
but I don't love that he didn't
naturally want to do that and I'm,
I'm allowed to feel that way naturally.
Wanting to do something
doesn't mean I don't
think you had enough choices
like let's say then that,
I mean that's a different conversation,
the whole conversation because
there's only 10 spots. I mean,
how many people does he love that are in
those 10 spots and why do one or two of
them have to be women who was on the
first season? I don't know. I don't know.
I have no idea. I really have only watched
two of them. I watched the one with, um,
not Eddie Izzard. What's
homeboy? Um, Eddie,
the other ready, other English Eddie.
God dammit. Famous guy. Not Eddie Izzard,
the other one. Eddie Murphy.
Of course. English guy.
What the fuck is his name?
Who was that other famous English guy?
That fucking other comedian
that's on all the time.
He must be one of the 10 funniest Jamie,
who's the other guy was on opie and
Anthony with them. Jesus fucking Christ.
I can't believe I can't remember
his name. Oh my God. Come on.
He's one of the 10 funniest people alive.
Thank you Ricky.
Gervais' fucking Christ.
Thank you very much.
Amy Schumer sister comes in the
clutch. I can't believe it. Sorry Rick.
And you're ready. Sorry. I was,
I was so blown away by Eddie Izzard
accomplishment of running a thousand miles
in steaming my brain. The
office? No, his, his um,
comedians in cars getting coffee.
Is that what you're asking? Okay,
so he did 10 funniest Reiki. I the only
one. I saw it, I started Ricky your vase.
And I saw Letterman. Those are the two
that I've seen. He's had a bunch of them.
Alec Baldwin, Larry,
Larry, David, Brian Regan.
He had a bunch of his friends. I mean
that's really essentially what he had.
He had 10 of his friends and they
happened to be all white guys. Yeah.
I think that triggers Chris Rock was on
there too though. Was that season one?
Season two.
Chris Rock was on season two
and then there's Louis
C K in there and uh,
Sarah Silvermans in there and see
these are the, what's funny is funny,
the 10 Michael Richards,
Karl Rahner,
Mel Brooks can't argue that whenever
Collin Quinn and Mario Joiner,
there's a black card, by the
way, Mario joinders, you know,
he's a good friend of his
and hilarious comedian. Look,
I don't think he's having
meetings and I just, he's,
he's putting the ball on that he thinks
is funny. Those are the people he got,
you know, I don't know. I can
see what you're saying and I,
but I don't think you're dealing with
somebody on my show because I thought they
filled like, of course some
diversity count. You know, like,
I think everybody should be able
to do, have whatever. If you,
if you never had girls ever on
your podcast, that's your choice.
And I would have feelings about it and
not because you should have to have them
because I like, I love that you love
women and think women are funny.
That's not how all of them though.
I like the funny ones.
That's the men.
There are still men who
are just like the women in the
clubs. I swear it, that's still,
that's still a thing.
Yeah.
Well I, and I don't think that
Seinfeld even feels that way.
I was going back to what I was saying
about Judy gold is that the conversation
that we had about,
um,
this interview that I did was what I was
trying to say in the interview, was it,
I think it's,
it's a way more difficult proposition.
Not saying that women can't be
funnier or better or you know,
more clever,
but I think that starting out,
there's reactions that a lot of people
have that are prejudice against women.
They don't necessarily have against men.
When a woman goes on stage,
I feel like she's a point behind
at least one, you know, right away,
especially if she goes on stage and she
has any sort of opinions about politics
or sexuality or anything.
I mean,
a lot of times women are forced in a
lot of ways to be self deprecating at a
level that a man isn't just
to sort of get in the door.
Well,
a guy doesn't want to listen to you
unless he thinks he could definitely fuck
you.
There's that.
Maybe for some people.
Well, I don't want to, I don't even
believe that. I don't even believe that,
but some guys, yeah. But, um,
I think, uh, I think Judy's
hilarious. I think, you know,
you know, I, I'm not like, I'm looking,
I'm looking at you and we're having this
conversation and I think like men are,
are all triggered by women
in general because it's like,
who's the woman you've known the longest?
Your mom and when she would talk to women
in general, I think when women taught,
yeah. When, when, when like a
woman is talking longer than
like, it can, it can just,
yeah,
I think it can.
I want a man's talking longer.
You want to beat the shit out of him as
a completely different reaction. Really.
Oh, and men are talking too long. You'd
like, dude, shut the fuck up. It's uh,
it's an uh, aggressively assaulting
on your senses sort of thing.
When a guy is like overbearing and
talks too much, men get angry. You know,
men might get bored if it wasn't,
everybody gets bored.
If anybody has shitty social cues,
if they're boring and monotonous and self
obsessed and they don't understand the
ins and the outs of a conversation,
the ebb and flow of two people
enjoying each other's company.
If one person just yapping at you like
I'm doing right now, just yapping at you.
I'm not even letting you talk.
No. You know what I'm saying?
I think you're right.
I think when you go on a stage as a woman,
when you start out, you have a strike
against you. Yes. More than one.
I think I have enjoyed that strike.
I kind of miss it because it was
really fun to go up there and surprise
everybody.
It still is.
Right. So like your first
joke, you get off, boom,
they start laughing and just
feel the tension, leave the room
and then you're like, yeah. And Yeah.
Then they have the other confidence
when I got eliminated from last comic
standing because I, I just, um, they're
bringing that show back. How dare they,
I know. And uh, and they mostly, uh,
JB smooth. Oh really? Yeah.
And He owes the last ones.
No, Jb Smith is fucking hilarious.
I got a great story about him,
but they showed me a clip,
one of my worst bombings ever following.
Oh, I went on before
him. Oh God. Oh my God.
He was supposed to go on first and
I was supposed to go on second.
We were working together in New Jersey
and he got lost. I got lost too.
It was a really hard place to find.
There was some weird fucking
college in New Jersey. So, um,
the for the show was already
like 20 minutes late and they,
Jamie's not here and I got there late
and they said we're going to wait for him
to come much,
just have a seat in the rec room.
So I sit down on the record when I start
watching this documentary on the Malibu
Fires and Oh my God,
is it depressing people who lost their
homes and this kid was calling out for
their dog.
They were hoping their dog made it and
they're walking smoldering fucking embers
of their house and they're
walking around rusty. Well,
you rusty the calling out for a dog and
then this guy comes down and he was a
fireman and he didn't even lose his house.
They saved his house,
but his neighbors lost her
house. And this guy was, we bing,
I mean openly weeping.
He was talking about how this house is
all he has and that he saved for 40 years
to build this house and this was his house
and he was so worried that he's going
to lose his house and he feels bad that
he's happy that he kept his house cause
his neighbors lost their house and he's
fucking crying and weeping and they go,
okay,
JB smooth is still not here so we're going
to have you go on stage so can you go
on stage now? And I was
like, yeah, okay, okay, yeah,
let me just get a water and I'll go on
stage. And I just went on stage and just,
I ate the shit buffet of my life and
my girlfriend was with me, you know,
and I tried to explain it to her why,
but she had seen me doing well before,
but I try to explain to her like I go,
there's no,
I was just not going to do good.
There's no way I would do good. I just,
it was horrible,
horrible experience.
So I went up there and just ate politesse
of Shit and then JB smooth shows up
after me and destroys just levels the
place and they were so happy to see him
because I was so terrible. Oh,
that's awful. And they were like,
he was really funny at
neck. I swear. He's funny.
Like I'd hear them talking when I
got off stage about how bad I was.
Like the people that booked it, they were
like trying to say at the convention.
He was very funny, was really funny and
just why we bought him. And then I go,
I'm sorry I watched that thing on the
fires. They go, why'd you do that?
And I'm like, you fucking sat me in that
room with the TV that was on. I didn't,
didn't flip the channel to that shit.
That's just was on.
I learned a lesson though.
He's valuable.
What you have in your mind right
before you go on stage. Very, very,
very important.
I've done it more than one times where
I've gone on stage after seeing something
awful. Let's just catch this
while they're introducing,
you read a book about the Kennedy
assassination once all day.
Read this book all day for like 10 hours
and then went on stage and
just eight deck. Just thomp.
Thomp thomp thomp thomp just
couldn't be fine. I was like,
take your fucking killed Kennedy.
They fucking killed Kennedy. Okay.
The Catholic was empty.
Okay.
There's a different in the autopsy report
for fucking rant and to anybody who to
listen to me.
Now you're just listening to the eye
of the tiger watching home alone. No,
now I just try to be relaxed and have fun.
I try.
I have a bunch of different
songs that I like to listen to.
I like to listen to like fun music,
you know, and have my friends around,
but no negativity and just I got know
even if something negative happens,
good energy. Yeah. Not Getting in there.
I gotta go see you giggle
all the way out of there.
More rocks and fucking tortures
are being thrown my way.
He got to know what to let
in and what not to let it in.
Right before you go onstage.
Super important,
especially when people pay to see you,
you know,
someone's going out there to see Amy
Schumer, you can't go on stage. Yeah.
I tried to do the best I've
ever done every time. That's
huge. That's everything.
I mean, that's what endears you to
fans. There's no other way around it.
And you remember what it was like
when you were a fan? You know,
Bill Burr was on the podcast and
he said it best and you know,
and sort of his own bill burr
type language. He goes, I
remember when I was a kid,
I go see a band. And uh,
and he goes see him, uh,
a year later and they fucking phone
it in and they just, they fuck,
I never forgot, you know, and I
just, uh, I make a deal with people.
I'm not going to fuck you. I'm not going
to five. No, I'm not going to fuck you.
I'm going to write new jokes.
I'm not going to fuck you.
I'm gonna work on. Yeah.
But he's a real artist, you know what
I mean? Is it really that guy? He's,
he's really a great comic. I mean, that's
what he's supposed to do in this life.
He found the perfect occupation.
He's fantastic at it and
he's got a real ethic for it.
There's a gang of them right now.
There's, you know, there's guys,
people that people haven't heard of
like Christina Palicki and Tom Segura is
gaining steam.
Those guys are getting,
staying with their podcast is gaining
steam and then there's people that people
forgot about like a towel.
You know,
I would pay to see them above
everybody else right now.
Meet Stan hope standing up over
everybody. He's my boy. He's so funny.
Yeah. Well there's a bunch
of great ones right now
I think is like, I need to see that.
You have to see her. I need to see her.
Joey Diaz is my all time favorite though.
If I had to choose one comic,
the last set that I ever got to see in
my life before the fucking great media
lands,
it's Diaz,
Diaz smoking a joint on
stage talking about his balls
plain right down. Are you enjoying
doing your show? Is it stressful?
It's, yeah, it's a lot of
work, but it's worth it, you
know. But it's a lot of work.
But the result you're,
you're enjoying the process.
You're enjoying the process
of making it. Yeah. Awesome.
It's getting great reviews.
It is, it is like, yeah.
Was like,
I'm going to make the show that I think
is really funny and I didn't know if,
if people were going to be into it or not.
There's a lot of darkness on your
show. Like, well, have you met me? Yes,
yes. Yeah. Well you're happy, dark
person. It's an unusual type of darkness.
It's not overwhelming. It's
not overbearing. It's the
better word. Yeah. You know,
it's a fun darkness and to
have fun. But I do, yeah,
my mind goes dark but it's
not like, yeah, I'm not like,
do you face any resistance like subject
matter wise or like the things you want
to cover? No, no, I don't think so.
Not really. No. Well that's awesome.
Yeah. But then it's like a lot of
pressure in here cause they're like, okay,
the network. Like, no, no,
it's well they're letting us
like this season we were like,
we don't think you should be bleeping
the word pussy. And they were like,
all right. We were like, woosh,
don't be a pussy or my pussy. Mm.
Either. Whoa. Big Heavy sexual.
Hmm. Hold on. It's never my buzzy.
No, it is my pussy. My pussy hurts.
Yeah. That's sexual. This is,
it depends on how you say it.
Yeah. Well that Black Dick,
damn, I'm it. Hers. Right.
My pussy hurts. Then it's just like, oh,
she's just talking about her past
and they said yes to that. Yeah.
It's not believed. And we
were like, what? It's awesome.
Welcome to the Internet
and the Internet exists.
You can't just fucking pretend those words
aren't being bantered around like one
of those real cool, bad mitten birds.
Just toss and pussy around these days.
Different world. I know I am. Yeah.
It's a different world. Right.
Do you know that's all self imposed?
All their restrictions on
language completely solved.
But I mean people, yeah,
they're just like scared.
They don't want to lose their job.
But I really appreciate them doing that.
Well it's not, they lose their job. It's
losing advertising revenue and you're,
the revenue they're getting from you is
you're already a controversial comedian.
You already tackling, you know,
dangerous subject matter or something.
Ah, you're throwing it out. I'm all
shit. I see what you're doing. Please.
Heat ain't funny. It's funny, right.
Whatever. Whatever. And then he is.
Um, so what about shit?
Shit. Get flies too, right?
What do you mean you can say bullshit,
right? You could say there's a,
I heard the phrase tonnage issue.
I think you can say shit like
a couple of times. Oh yeah.
Now if your show airs late at night,
like after a certain time, is it,
do they have a difference in what
they believe and what they don't?
Cause I know they do it stand up.
Um, yeah, totally. You can. Yeah. If
there's a lot less bleeps after. Right.
There's subject matter restrictions
though. Even in the unbleached one.
What's interesting, like they bleeped
some shit out when they aired.
My standup special,
my last special.
They bleep some shit out
of the earlier stuff. She,
they bleeped some shit of the earlier
stuff that they left that they edited out
of the unedited stuff. Yeah. Like they
decided like without the bleeping,
it's just, it's just, yeah. This gay
marriage time machine bit I have, yeah.
Well we, what? I love that you did it. You
did an Atlanta, right? Yeah. Yeah. Why?
Why did you choose Atlanta? I love
Atlanta. I love it. I love it too.
It's an awesome city.
Yeah. It's one of those
cities that people don't, they
sleep on it. Sleep on Atlanta.
Atlanta's a great city and it's, people
are ready to go nuts. They're very,
it's a very diverse city too. It's a,
it's a lot of diversity in Atlanta.
There's a lot of,
like,
there's a lot of alternative people as
far as like tattooed up and piercings.
There's a lot of like real southern
people. There's a lot of black people,
a lot of black, like um,
people that are professionals.
Like a lot of black lawyers.
You run into a lot of black more.
So I think you see more integration of
black and white folks like hanging out
and partying together.
You know,
I see that more in Atlanta
than I do almost anywhere.
And I'm sure racism still exists.
I'm not naive, but I think that I,
I enjoy the diversity when I go out in
Atlanta. I think it's, uh, you know,
so much so that I've
thought about living there.
It's a lot of nonsense in Atlanta to
Atlanta,
like celebrities of houses
there. It's not a bad spot. Yeah,
it's the same vibe there.
Like age, nothing matters.
Everybody's like just hanging out.
Well,
I think whenever you have people that
are more inclined to be partying,
you're gonna have people that are more
inclined to be fun, you know? I mean,
that's just the reality of
the world that we live in.
And you can pretend to be noble by like
what you were talking about earlier,
like abstaining from sex or abstaining
from things that you enjoy. Yeah,
you can pretend to be knowable,
but let's get the fuck over that.
This is nonsense. Some
drinks and have fun. Right.
And who's going to be more inclined
to do that is people that are more
comfortable with it. You know,
I love that place. It's great.
The less restrictions people
have, the more I think, you know,
people can come to like a comfortable
state on their own without being oppressed
because that oppression is always
going to make people spring back.
And the other way, if you tell people
they can't drink, they want to drink more,
tell people to can't fuck. They fucked
behind every goddamn closed door.
You can find a Catholic school.
I dated this girl in Catholic
school when I talk about her,
this poor girl could not, she could
not help herself if you rolled a dick.
I was like a ball of yarn in front
of a kid and she was just dive on it.
She even know what she was doing.
She would dive on it like a crazy
person like she, she literally like,
it's unfair if a guy pulled his cock out
in front of her because for her it was
just like a fucking leper. Khan showed
up at the bottom of the rainbows, like,
look, I've got the gold suppression,
suppression,
Catholic suppression,
all that crazy human beings
don't like to be told,
I have children and I have daughters.
I see it very clearly when you tell
them what to do. I want to do it anyway.
But if you rationalize with them and
have conversations with them and say,
listen,
you can't do it because it's raining
outside and it gets dangerous and this is
electricity and electricity causes sparks,
so you can't do it.
Can't go outside with this.
Oh, okay. But I want to,
I know it looks like fun.
You got to go to bed.
I want to stay away,
but you gotta be up in eight hours
and you gotta be really tired.
I know you want to get, but listen,
just relax. We'll read some studies.
I co I have these like rationalization
conversations with them to try to
avoid that backlash that comes from being
an overbearing parent or an overbank
teacher. Yeah. Those that
people don't like that shit.
Nobody likes you telling them
what to do just the way it is.
That's why suppression
doesn't work in any form,
whether it's sexual suppression
or suppressed making, you know,
alcohol difficult to get ahold of.
People want it, they want it even more.
Look what the fuck is going on
in Portugal. You know, they,
they decriminalized all drugs
and they have way lower cases of,
um, of um, uh,
HIV way lower cases of addiction there,
there,
there all these numbers drop their society
like leveled out because there wasn't
this massive stigma attached
to all this stuff anymore.
I know that last night,
I don't mean why not? Why
Not Porch? I just probably,
I think if you go somewhere
in another country,
I mean the only ones I go for work,
I would at least want to
acquire a rudimentary grasp
of the language just out of
respect. That's tough. It's very hard.
Spain, like you think he speaks Spanish
and they're like, well no bed actually.
Well in France apparently, you know,
everybody like talk shit about the French.
But from my experience or my friends'
experiences that I've talked to them,
they say as long as you try,
as long as you like and make some
effort to communicate with them,
they're very polite. They don't like
as Americans, like how much is this?
Can I give you American money? And like
shake it in front of their face. Yeah,
no, in span. And you're like,
say something in Spanish and they
would answer you in English and you're,
Oh really? Yeah, but yeah, but
yeah, yeah. Sorry. They're like $20.
Did you like Spain? I loved it. My
Buddy Chris lived there for a few years.
Um,
he lived in Barcelona.
Oh, the guy because he, he
used the Castilian Lisp and
it was just the two of us.
You'd be like
Barcelona,
not of you're from Jersey over there.
They say Barcelona.
Yeah. Really? I mean, not
all over Spain, but if you're
in Barcelona they do it.
Yeah. [inaudible] Barcelona.
It's called the Castilian
Lisp. Yeah. That's fascinating.
I've learned a new thing from Amy Schumer.
I had no idea that was the case.
Probably 30 hours total. And
that's, that's the newest thing.
I'm sure I've learned some things
in the past. Let me review them.
Don't get touching.
Well,
he said that he never learned anything
from me and he was implying and I was a
dumb girl.
That's what it triggered me.
I'm just fucking with you.
I learned a Barcelona,
Barcelona Castilian lift.
You're just talking to your girlfriend
and she knows you're from New Jersey and
all of a sudden just the two of
you and you're like, oh, Barcelona.
And you're like,
mmm.
Barcelona. Say it. Say a
bitch. You know who we are.
It's been, yeah, a spawn. Yeah. Like when
the next time we go to Spania, wait, what?
What, what you mean Spain? The fuck
are you saying you're from Trenton?
I, you know, I believe when
you're over there in the culture,
you should mirror through yourself and
like we're in a hotel room and it's just
the two of us. A lot of annoying fucking
people out there and Amy Schumer.
But if it wasn't for them, we would
have less to talk about. Very true.
We wouldn't have as much fun to comedy.
We have to air grievances and a
microphone in front of drunk people. Yeah,
and well not only that,
there's a give and a take to the universe
and if everything was all blissful,
we would have literally nothing to talk
about or talk shit about on stage. Oh,
thank God. It's far from that. Was that
chaos? We wouldn't exist, Amy Schumer.
Okay. Not Exist as comedians. It'd
be known. There was no need for us.
If everyone achieved enlightenment, we're
a dinosaur. We just don't know it yet.
As soon as the fucking the, the machine
plugs in and everybody becomes one.
The trends in dental mind, universal
mind mesh happens due to technology.
We're at a business. You got to stock
up all this inside Amy Schumer money.
Now I can.
Okay.
Because once the fucking singularity
hits you and I are fucked is when's a
singularity and any day now,
probably 24 39 but any day now can
happen is you get some sneakers.
One's dude from silicone valley or one
Gao or one guy in another country is
going to come up with something,
some fucking invention that's going to
change the whole game and flip it right
on its head and we're all going to be
able to read each other's minds and there
will be no more jokes.
I'm more worried that I forgot
to Tivo divas on he this week.
I think you probably get that on demand.
We live in a new era.
You can get a lot on demand. A lot of
shows are shows it going on demand.
I see what you did that diffuse with
comedy. Isn't that what we're doing?
We're good at it. Inside Amy
Schumer sign tomorrow night. Right.
To seem more like an interview than
any conversation I've ever had with,
you know. Oh well it's usually like a
bunch of animals in here. Yeah. Well No,
it's just the um, the, the,
the breaking down the mindset,
you know, like fuck process.
I love talking to you too.
Glad we do it more often.
Yeah, let's do it. When
are you back here again?
I'm here in the next two weeks and then
I'm not. Okay. All right. Wow. I miss you.
You going back to New York?
Yeah. Escaping with the money.
Leaving with our milk and honey.
Right.
Going back to your dirty city on the
other side of the wound back. The goal.
It's not cold anymore.
You can return to your last right
joy. You're hedging your
bets against earthquakes,
but been living here a few months out of
the year. I see what you're doing. God,
I'm scared. Yeah. I just had my first one.
It was not fun. I think my pool's broken.
I know it's a crack in my
brain. Oh my God. I'm fine.
I'm rich. I think it's really,
that's the funniest thing I've ever heard.
I think my pool's broken.
I don't know what kind of gas.
My antiques,
I noticed the crack in it the other day.
I don't think the earthquake got me.
These bitches,
these motherfuckers in the earthquake.
The really crazy thing is those proport
crazy assholes that live on those hills.
Like when you go through Laurel and you
drive up the Canyon and he sees people
that are literally pee perched on on
these, these still are you going to do?
It's crazy.
I watched one house fall apart when I was,
when I first moved here and wasn't a
really big earthquake. It was a small,
you know what? Actually I want to say,
it may not have even been an earthquake.
It was a landslide and it
was a landslide, um, on,
uh, on Laurel Canyon. I
guess you're going up,
but if you headed towards the Improv,
if you're going up the valley
on the right hand side,
there's this house that the back of it
just came down and just crush the house
and it was only that house on the street.
So I'm pretty sure it was just a local
landslide. Just destroy this entire house,
pushed it off its foundation.
It happened really recently in Malibu too,
like with,
over the last couple of years there was
a neighborhood where these people got
woken up in the middle of the night.
He's Bang Bang noises and it was their
house breaking apart and falling down the
hill and they escape.
They ran out of the house just in time
where half their house went tumbling into
the canyon.
How do you sleep like a baby?
You really do like a bear,
like a hibernating bear.
Like I barely got shot with a
tranquilizer dart. That's actually
because I feel like you're like,
I just, I run out of gas though.
I just 10 minutes on
stage, I'm just like, nope,
we're gonna get out of here. I'm going
to work out at midnight and then, um,
I'll work out for like an hour or so and
then I'll be exhausted by the time two
o'clock in the morning
rolls out and then I'm out.
Yo [inaudible] how long do you sleep
when you wait hours to see paid hours
tomorrow.
Got to get up a little bit early because
I got to do some ESPN type shit. Oh,
nice. You've got to talk
about some fights, upcoming
fights on Fox this weekend.
I'm also, I'm a fox analyst. I don't
know if you know, I'm a sports analyst.
I can't, no, I, I can't believe
like the, yeah. Why you're
like, you're beyond say,
um, are you sure? Oh,
definitely not her or Eddie Izzard
runs marathons. I'm just talking.
It's a lot harder to run the marathons.
I wouldn't do it.
Use your mind like, you know, like I
get tired playing chess. Like I, if I,
if somebody is like, oh, this stuff
with the, the plane, like I just,
my mind just shuts off.
It's just too much for me to
process and I'm just like Zzz Zzz
but you don't get tired
when you're working on your
show, right? I mean, you do,
but you're so enthusiastic about it,
right? Yeah. No. Yeah. Okay. Surely.
Same thing. It's a completely, exactly
the same size. They get different mindset.
Well, it's just what do you,
you're not passionate about chess.
If you're playing chess, you'd be like,
Oh my God, I'm investing too much energy.
And there was fuck this.
But if you're working on your show,
trying to put a sketch, very
meticulous in series about it. Yeah.
It's the same thing with me.
I'm just lucky that it was like more
than one thing that I do like, you know,
between the comedy and the
podcasting and the UFC stuff,
they're all just fun things to me. Yeah.
So it's just a bunch of fun shit to do.
So. And talk to my friend
Amy. That's a fun sheet.
Thank you. Thank you. Have Fun in Orlando.
We're going to have a good time.
Me and mad flavor. Aka Joey Diaz.
Inside Amy Schumer is on Tuesdays at
8:00 PM 10 30 10 30 what time La Tom,
is it a east coast, west coast thing?
The air over twice at east coast.
10 30 I got the direct TV, you know,
so sometimes some of the things,
well some of the things
air on east coast time.
What I'm trying to say is check your
local listings. Ladies and gentlemen,
inside Amy Schumer.
Who else is on that lineup on a Tuesday
night on comedy central? Yeah. Oh,
that's beautiful. Oh, what a great
wave. Oh, that's, that is the spot.
That's like the spot after friends used
to be on like Thursday night on NBC.
I'm a bunch of shitty ones. Caroline in
the city. It was terrible. Oh my God.
Caroline in the city. Yeah. Caroline,
the shitty they used to call it.
She was nice too. I can picture
that just wasn't a good show.
It was better than the single guy though.
I remember that one.
Wheezes.
Don't remember.
I blocked it out. Really? Yeah, like
a finger bang and Catholic school.
You got finger banged again? No, I didn't,
but I blocked it out as if it was. That
probably was a good show. I'm just
talking shit. I don't remember it at all.
Literally Tuesday night. 10 30 alright,
we're done. Thank you. You're awesome.
Amy schumer.com is that your
website? Yeah. Okay, beautiful.
Go there everybody and
follow her on Twitter. Uh,
s c h u m e R and Amy Schumer
and the fucking house.
Beautiful. That was fun. Thank
you. And thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to honor to God on at.com o n n
I t go to [inaudible] dot com use the
code word Rogan and save 10%
off any and all supplements.
Thanks also to stamps.com go to stamps.com
and use the code word j r e for your
beautiful $110 bonus software,
delicious and nutritious stamps.com.
Thanks.
Also to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com and enter the code
word Joe for a free trial and 10% off
your first purchase of the most awesome
website building website known to man.
Okay, where are we back? Uh, tomorrow.
Got a lot of shit going on this week,
ladies and gentlemen.
Uh,
tomorrow is the fighter and the
kid with Brennan Shab and um,
and and Brian Callan.
And then on Wednesday,
David Seaman returns.
And we're going to have a lot of fun.
So a much love to everybody. Big
Kiss. Oh, Wednesday night ice house.
I were doing a 10:00 PM show at the
Ice House so far. It's Ari Shaffir,
Duncan Trussell, Tony Hinchcliffe and
me. I'm sure more people will be added.
10:00 PM show,
15 bucks can't go wrong in your life.
If you live and you love comedy,
you must go to the ice house.
Even if I'm not there
anybody there at one time.
It's the oldest comedy club in
the country. It's in Pasadena.
It's been there since 61 all right.
Go Fuck Yourself. We'll see. Saying.